hello everyone welcome to the march 2022
ask me anything edition of the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll a
little bit late coming out this month
sorry it's march 5th
i usually try to get it out by mark by
the beginning of the month but things
have been hectic things are probably
going to be hectic again next month lots
of things i'm supposed to be doing other
than doing amas so we get when we get it
there you go um for those of you who are
listening i don't know far in the future
or whatever uh the world is in bad shape
at the moment we in the last couple
weeks have had the russian invasion of
ukraine which is intrinsically bad uh
the plucky ukrainians are fighting back
as best they can nato and the us are
trying to help them in various different
ways without actually getting into a
shooting war with russia which could
lead to world war iii that's where we
are right now in the world i don't have
a lot of wisdom about that particular
conflict although
it's easy after the fact of course to
say well we should have done a lot more
before the conflict started to prevent
it from happening in the first place the
west does have the ability to put
economic squeeze on russia in order to
prevent it from doing things like that
but we didn't and you know international
cooperation is not always easy and it's
certainly never fast uh but of course
this invasion has brought a whole bunch
of countries together
on the other side in ways that were
unanticipated so i guess there's a tiny
little silver lining i mean everyone
knows everyone in in the current era
here
listening to the news etc has just
enormous respect and admiration for the
people of ukraine who are fighting to
keep their homeland and not be part of
the russian dictatorship um and it's
heartbreaking because you know it's very
very plausible i would say that it won't
work you know and maybe it works i
certainly hope that they're able to
maintain their sovereignty uh but
they're a tiny country against a big
country and so who knows and so um i'm
not optimistic about that but i i keep
my fingers crossed and there's of course
a whole bunch of other things going on
in the world uh politicians are doing
stupid things as usual we still have a
pandemic that we're going through
yeah it's tough to um keep your eyes on
the positive aspects of things i just
put up a tweet with a picture of ariel
uh just to cheer people up a little bit
that's the best i can do i can offer
kitty pictures um but you know i'm
actually a believer that even in very
very trying times
uh and
i should say needless to say these times
are not nearly as trying for me uh or
for americans more generally as they are
for other people throughout the world so
a bit of empathy there i'm not trying to
make it as if my personal situation is
all that bad compared to that of others
um but it is actually important i think
to kind of not become too mono maniacal
about these things especially when these
things
involve
world events that you or i individually
have very little control over you know
life is complicated and rich and
multifaceted and there will be bad
things going on and good things at the
same time and i don't think it's a
mistake to acknowledge both
so just because terrible things are
happening uh it's okay to remember that
there are some good things happening and
vice versa even if things are going very
well it's important to keep in mind that
things aren't going well for everybody
and and they could be better in working
to make them better so
this is a very long-winded way of saying
i think it's okay to have an ask me
anything episode of the mindscape
podcast even when the world is falling
apart
uh the world doesn't stop it doesn't
just come to a halt even when bad things
are happening and it's important to sort
of keep our chins up and think about big
questions that have an eternal aspect to
them as well as the pressing questions
of the moment we can do both that's the
point we should be able to multi-task on
this
so as always if you aren't a regular
listener here this is the ask me
anything episode for mindscape we do
this once a month except for
the end of the year and the questions
are asked by supporters of mindscape on
patreon so if you would like to be a
supporter you can go to patreon.com sean
m
uh and pledge your support to this
little project that we have going on
here and uh you get to ask a question
back in the days when we were a we
plucky podcast everyone who asked a
question would get it answered these
days are too many questions sorry about
that uh
but i try to
answer the questions that i think i have
something interesting to say about you
know as usual every single month there's
more and more really really good
questions that i don't get to answer so
my heart breaks i would like to be able
to answer all the questions but there's
lots of things i'd like to be able to do
that i can't quite get done there you go
that's the world the constraints of
reality in time and space and energy and
effort and ability gotta deal with them
and with that
with that not completely optimistic
conclusion let's go
[Music]
crafter lucas says after all this time i
still don't understand why people chose
to be bayesians when it comes to
epistemology for example where does
knowledge actually come from within a
bayesian framework and how does it deal
with entirely new ideas i.e with no
relation to any priors
well i think as i said before you have
to separate out two different things one
is baze's theorem and basis theorem is a
theorem it's just right no one is
allowed to disagree with it unless you
disagree with basic facts about math and
logic and baze's theorem says that when
we have some credences and some
propositions and then new evidence comes
to bear here's a formula that tells you
how you change your credences so you're
sort of not allowed to disagree with
that formula if you accept the basic
axioms but bayesian epistemology
or bayesian inference or you know
whatever you want to call it is a
slightly more broad scope kind of set of
claims where you're saying that
that is
the way that we should think about
gaining new knowledge you always start
with some credences and you always
update them now there's many many
details that are worth trying to get
into here like when i say new knowledge
okay new data what counts as new data is
it literally new facts about the world
that we've been empirically measuring or
can a new insight
count as new data in some sense and i
think the clear answer is yes new
insight definitely counts as new data if
you realize that your
proposition is actually predicting
something that is true even though you
didn't originally realize that then that
should increase your likelihood um in
that particular your credence if you
like in that particular uh proposition
so the question i take it is
that uh the usual i mean maybe i'm not
sure krath or luka if i am
force-feeding or forcing your question
into a framework that i understand but
um
the usual question is about the priors
okay so a bayesian starts with prior
credences you have to start somewhere
and then you update them and everyone
agrees on the updating the priors are
sort of philosophically
uh
difficult i mean where do they come from
i take it that that is the basic
question here uh yeah so they come from
human beings inventing priors
as i as i joked i forget whether it was
in the big picture one of my other books
uh
everyone is entitled to their own priors
no one is entitled to their own
likelihoods the likelihoods or the
functions that tell you the likelihood
of getting certain data given some
proposition being true but everyone's
entitled to their own priors so where do
they come from they come from the fact
that we are human beings embedded in the
world our brains are not blank slates we
have models of the world we have the
manifest image we believe in three
dimensions of space around us and
gravity and all sorts of things like
that continuity over time of various
course features of the world
and that brain as part of the physical
universe has opinions it just has
opinions whether you like it or not even
if you give somebody a proposition that
they have never contemplated before
they can come up with a prior on whether
or not they think that proposition is
true or not different people will have
different priors the hope is
that they can collect enough data so
that their priors go away i mean that's
always the hope of bayesian epistemology
which is a fancy way of saying that
we do science to the world that's how we
make progress we gather data and it
doesn't matter what our initial opinions
were if those opinions become flagrantly
in conflict with the data we get rid of
them
so
philosophically you might not like that
idea that our brains come up with these
priors in in different ways in
fundamentally subjective ways
i just think that that's it that's
there's no other there's no better way
to do it than that you know there's no
uh out there in the world objective
handle that we have um you know i think
that this is part of my own intellectual
journey i was a
a person
so many years ago who was as
foundationalist as anybody you know who
really thought that we should go looking
for absolutely solid grounding for all
of our beliefs including beliefs about
morals and aesthetics and so forth and
the more and more i think about it the
more and more i read the more and more i
uh
exist in the world and try to make sense
of it the more subjective i believe that
some things are the physical world is
not subjective there's a real honest
world out there
but when you say okay how do these
little agents called human beings
develop knowledge about the world
there's going to be a necessarily
subjective feature there there's not a
rock hard foundation on which to build
an unbreakable edifice of pure knowledge
maybe we'd like that to be true but i
don't think it is
anonymous says if you take our
observable world and retrodict without a
past hypothesis
what are some concrete ways your
retroaddiction would look like the
future in ways your retrodictions would
look like the real past
i.e does ice melt but the rotation of
the earth reverses do star shine et
cetera okay so the setup for this
question is
the era of time question we think that
entropy is increasing toward the future
for two reasons one is because starting
from today
we start with some coarse-grained
information about the world right we
don't know the micro state of the world
we don't know every atom and molecule
and what they're doing but we know some
coarse observable features of it and we
have a probability distribution of what
the microstates could be doing within
that macroscopic set of constraints and
so you can from that predict the future
in some probabilistic way okay now you
could also try to predict the past but
in fact what we actually think happened
in the past is utterly different than
what you would get
just on the basis of predicting from the
current macro state we think the entropy
of the universe was lower in the past
and so we assume that the early universe
started with very very low entropy
that's the past hypothesis and then we
conditionalize on that when we make
predictions if you will about the past
we don't just say starting with our
current information
we say starting with our current
information and the hypothesis that the
past had very low entropy what do we
reconstruct about the past and this is
so ingrained in how we think that it is
very difficult to break out of just
assuming that past hypothesis and so in
particular
if you didn't have it this is the
question asked by anonymous if you
didn't have the past hypothesis if you
only had
information about the current macro
state of the world what would you
predict about the past and future
and the important thing here is this
division of knowledge into microstates
and macrostates okay so um the earth
going around the sun has a macro state
and let's imagine that that macrostate
is just defined by the center of mass of
the earth where it's located how it's
moving and maybe it's rotation or
something like that it's already you're
already noticing that the level of
coarse graining is important for some
people astronomers it's usually okay
just treat the earth as a point going
around the sun for geologists it's not
good enough you need to take care of all
the mountains and oceans and things like
that but we're being astronomers right
now okay
so that is a macro state because we're
ignoring details of what all the
molecules and the particles in the earth
are doing
and when you say i take the current
macro state
and evolve it backward in time without a
past hypothesis
what happens is you know to evolve
backward in time you just imagine
reversing the momentum right
reversing the momentum of every object
and evolving it forward in time is the
same gives you the same kind of answer
as just evolving backward in time so for
imagination purposes it's useful to
think about reversing the momentum
and that macro state of the earth has a
momentum right it is moving around the
sun the center of mass of the earth and
so that would reverse so that's just a
fancy way of saying that if the earth is
moving around in a certain direction
toward the future
it would still move backward uh toward
the past the earth moving around the sun
is a physical system that has very small
numbers of moving parts to the earth and
the sun
as long as we can ignore some very very
tiny tidal effects and outgassing and
things like that
and it's very very predictable right
there's no entropy increase or decrease
as the earth goes around the sun there's
entropy increase or decrease because of
radiation and things but we're ignoring
that for right now
so you can easily retrodict the uh earth
going backward that's no problem at all
he reversed that momentum what you don't
do is reverse all the microscopic
momentum you're not allowed to do that
because you don't know what they are
because you only know the current macro
state
so roughly speaking if all you knew is
the current macro state if you want to
know what you predict for the past it is
exactly the same as what you predict for
the future okay except for these
macroscopic momenta being reversed so in
particular
you predict that toward the future the
sun is shining
what does that mean that means that
there's radiation that is leaving the
sun and escaping to infinity escaping to
distant space so if you had a little
meter that was counting the flux of
electromagnetic radiation you would get
a lot of flux going from the direction
of the sun out into the opposite
direction
if you retrodict the past without a past
hypothesis you predict the opposite of
that which is
you predict radiation
flowing from the sun into the past
if that makes sense that's it's
equivalent to saying you predict
radiation coming toward the sun okay
if you had a little meter there in the
past it would detect a strong amount of
radiation coming toward the sun from
empty space
and you you say to yourself well why in
the world how does it know how does that
radiation know to go toward the sun but
the point is without the past hypothesis
the current moment in the history of the
universe is very very special we do not
live in thermal equilibrium we are in a
relatively low entropy state compared to
thermal equilibrium so that's why
entropy can still increase toward the
past but without the past hypothesis
entropy also in sorry i said increased
toward the past i meant that's why
entropy does increase toward the future
starting from now without the past
hypothesis it would also increase toward
the past in exactly the same way so the
reason why this radiation focusing in on
the sun
knows to do that is because the sun
right now is in a very special low
entropy state all things considered if
you don't think that there was an even
lower entropy state before that of
course this seems weird because we have
a intuitive feeling about how cause and
effect works
and uh the arrow time is built into that
but you've erased the arrow of time uh
toward the past by saying we have no
past hypothesis so you're going to get
some weird behavior
dan pie says given the fuzzy nature of
the term emergence strong and weak
meaning almost the opposite of each
other do you think there could be room
for to somewhat expand the meaning of
the much less used word consilience to
capture what is usually meant by weak
emergence understanding that it usually
refers to agreement between academic
disciplines it has a strong overlap with
agreement between levels of reality
and reconciling different ways of
speaking about the same reality
i think that consilience is is related
and a fine thing to think about but it's
not the same it doesn't capture the same
meaning as weak emergence because
consilience would be completely possible
if there were no higher levels right i
mean it's it's compatible with the idea
that it's just one level that you can
talk about
the statement of weak emergence is the
statement that there is there are
additional patterns that we can sort of
grasp and make predictions using using
only macroscopic information right you
don't need in the example we just gave
to know all the details about all the
particles in the earth to predict what
it how is going to revolve around the
sun
and that is an example of weak emergence
of course x post facto there is
consilience with thinking about the
earth as a point with its center of mass
versus thinking of the earth as 10 to
the 50th atoms and molecules
but there's an extra fact that is
conveyed when you say there is a weekly
immersion higher level description so i
don't think that it's a good substitute
for that kind of vocabulary carlos nunez
says what's your view on the trade-off
between free speech and misinformation
is it okay for platforms to restrict
freedom of speech if that has a
considerable positive effect on social
welfare
you know it's hard to answer these
questions they're important questions
but it's hard to answer in the abstract
i think it's there's a temptation
similar to what i just talked about a
second ago there's a temptation like
find a simple rule and let's just apply
it absolutely and unthinkingly once
you've made up the rule but the real
world is a little messier and more
complicated than that i mean if you
take this question at face value is it
okay for platforms to restrict freedom
of speech
platforms can't restrict freedom of
speech they can only restrict what you
do on that platform right freedom of
speech was never supposed to be the
freedom to say whatever you want on any
platform you chose no one ever had the
right to say i would like to print
something on the front page of the new
york times the new york times has some
legal obligation to print it okay
there is a difference now than in the
past that we do have the technological
capabilities to allow people
anyone to use a certain platform but we
never do allow anyone there's always
people who are banned from these
platforms for misbehavior of one form or
another
um and that's perfectly legal and
perfectly legitimate so
it would be nice in in terms of sort of
simplicity and clarity to say everyone
can say whatever they want but no one
ever says that nor should they say that
so you have to do the hard work you have
to do the hard work of saying okay how
do we balance
the uh consideration of letting people
have as much free speech as
we can possibly get away with
with considerations of both social
welfare and the rights of the people who
make the platforms right i mean the true
libertarian response to this would be
make your own platform if you don't like
it and i think i don't think that's a
completely uh convincing response either
because
you know it's easy to say that it's hard
to actually do it there are lock-in
effects there are monopolies there's a
whole bunch of
issues going on that we can't sweep
under the table but
at face value yes it is okay for
platforms to kick people off of them um
if there are good reasons to do so now
clearly delineating what are the good
reasons etc that's hard work and there's
no way we're gonna make it anything
other than hard work we need to do that
work
andrew jaffe says in any of the many
worlds is there a better trade than the
hardin for sims for simmons trade what
do you now think of the sixers chances
for winning it all this year so those of
you who do not follow basketball
might not be aware of the uh epic
trade that was made by former mindscape
guest daryl mori president of basketball
operations for the philadelphia 76ers uh
ben simmons one of the sixers all-star
players uh became unhappy for various
reasons that i will not go into demanded
to be traded
and james harden another all-star player
who was playing for the brooklyn nets
and previously had played for daryl mori
in houston
also became unhappy at the same time and
so the two teams traded their headaches
for each other
and i
think i'm very biased as a sixers fan
but i think the sixers came out of that
trade great i could not imagine uh it
really working out better i'm sad
because we lost two really good other
players in uh
um seth curry and andre drummond as well
as a couple draft picks but james harden
and joel embiid and tyreese maxie are
just perfect compliments to each other i
do think that the sixers will have um a
learning curve i don't think it's all
going to be uh they're not going to go
undefeated let's put it that way between
here in the playoffs uh especially on
the defensive end i think on the
offensive end it's just going to work
perfectly and that's something that i've
never said about the sixers since like
1983 um that we've really had a killer
offensive uh scheme in place uh but the
early returns are that unsurprisingly to
me james harden and joel embiid who are
both all-stars and basketball geniuses
work really well together so uh
optimistic if we can stop other people
from scoring uh we'll go very far so i
do think i actually think the sections
have a very good chance of winning it
all this year i think that the only team
i would clearly put ahead of them is uh
phoenix if they get chris paul back then
i think that phoenix deserves to be
the favorite team to win it all this
year but the sixers are right up there
okay i'm going to lump together group
together two questions one is by sandro
stuckey who says i'm amazed by the
length and quality of the ask me
anything episodes the number of
questions left here by patron patrons
patrons is it patreons or it's probably
patrons i think sandra you're correct
just seems to go up and up
can you tell us about your process for
making an ama episode how much time does
it take you to select and edit the
questions to record them to prepare the
auto material for upload etc
and then frank layman says in your ama
instructions you explicitly note i am
not a huge fan of special relativity
puzzles and paradoxes i'm curious what
is it about these kinds of scenarios you
don't like fielding okay so two
questions
two meta questions about the ama process
itself so thank you sandro
it's a good way to get your question
chosen by uh first saying how amazing
the podcast is that's always a very
it's a strategy worth trying let's just
put it that way um you know i think that
i'm impressed by the quality of
questions by both their variety you know
they're not the same things over and
over again and by
uh the depth you know it's it's a fun
mix of different things i like the
trivial fun questions and if i don't
answer your trivial fun question it's
not because i'm
uh you know trying to diss you or
anything like that it's just because i
don't have a good fun answer to give you
that's all
um so the process is you know we're
getting i don't know between 100 and 200
questions per ama
each month and so i cut and paste all of
them from the patreon post into a text
file
and then i go through them all
and i just read them and decide which
ones i have a possibility of saying
anything interesting about and deleting
the ones that i don't and you know with
a rough idea of how long the thing
should be i think that the long-term
equilibrium here is between two and
three hours for the length of these i
can't do three and a half or four-hour
amas every month i just don't have it in
me but uh given that constraint you know
and so it does take some time to do that
it takes a few hours to not i mean the
copy and pasting is easy but reading
them all
uh grouping questions that belong
together putting them in a sensible
order thinking about what my answers are
going to be that takes a few hours
then recording is pretty easy you know
look i'm not writing out answers i'm
just you know talking off the
spur of the moment given that i've
answered i've read the question ahead of
time but otherwise there's no
preparation or anything like that as i
also say in the ama instructions i'm not
going to answer questions that involve
me doing homework so there's no not that
much extra effort it's uh
the amount of time to record
is the amount of is the length of the
episode plus i don't know half an hour
you know just for because there will be
some interruptions the phone rings
whatever i have to do a little bit of
editing noise reduction in audacity and
and things like that and then posting is
another you know i don't know at most
20 minutes or something like that so i
mean that that i've gotten down to a
science otherwise i could not keep doing
mindscape on a regular basis if i i
didn't get the recording editing posting
down to a pretty efficient system then i
would not be able to uh work very
efficiently so
you know all in all between recording
and editing and things like that and
choosing the questions it's not a full
day's work but on that order roughly
speaking
frank says uh what about the special
relativity puzzles paradoxes why not
well you know part of it is because
there's not a lot of
intellectual progress made in talking
about special relativity puzzles and
paradoxes i completely recognize that
there's plenty of people out there who
are not experts in special relativity
and for whom these questions are
endlessly fascinating i get it
um but i don't actually think of my own
role or the parts of this role that i
enjoy the most as being a physics
professor you know i'd like being a
physics professor but i do that
already
uh i i want to
move the frontier of knowledge forward
not just clean up the frontier of
knowledge in the regime we're already in
so special relativity puzzles and
paradoxes are not i mean it's not a real
puzzle or real paradox it's just that we
don't understand it because we're so
used to speaking an ordinary
pre-relativistic language of taking
space and time as separate things i mean
as soon as you say
i have a rod that is one meter long boom
you're already not thinking
relativistically because real rods are
not one-dimensional things they're
four-dimensional world volumes right and
you've already cheated by saying i have
a rod one meter long as soon as you
start thinking in space-time terms from
the start most of these special
relativity puzzles and paradoxes just
evaporate and that's a journey we all
got to go on on
our own and it's just it's just sort of
like a little redundant and not new and
fun for me to go over that uh this is
not you know quora or reddit or
something like that this is not uh you
know let's solve our favorite uh physics
puzzle kind of thing i i immense respect
and and uh appreciation for that kind of
activity it's just not what i'm
interested in doing here
benjamin zand says does the coordinate
system we choose for the metric and
general relativity tell us something
about the location of the observer for
example where is the observer in the
original coordinate system used in the
short shield metric uh no
coordinate systems have nothing to do
with observers and again this is
something where i just talked about the
intellectual transition from newtonian
space-time to special relativity here's
a transition from special relativity to
general relativity
in special relativity you know it's
called relativity because different
observers measure different things okay
and it's all okay
the real physical stuff is invariant but
different observers you know measure
different amounts of elapsed time
between different events and things like
that
but there's still a a very simple space
time that you're in minkowski space that
has a lot of symmetries and so this
idea that an
observer can send out can construct a
coordinate system by sort of sending out
signals all around and you know building
a little system of rods and clocks is
still perfectly valid in special
relativity and general relativity is
just not you just generally can't do
that you can send out two light signals
and they could intersect at some point
in the future or whatever
or there's a great deal of arbitrariness
and how you might imagine doing that so
it never was true even in special
relativity even in newtonian mechanics
that there was some relationship between
observers and coordinate systems
but
for certain approximations in certain
circumstances it made sense to act as if
it were true so we're always talking
about the reference frame associated
with an observer and there's a kind of
complicated construction that is in the
back of your mind when you say that in
general relativity that's just no longer
a useful thing so we're more honest in
general relativity we just say you have
a coordinate system
and you also have maybe observers and
they have nothing necessarily to do with
each other in particular if there's
multiple observers they're all going to
be moving in different places in the
coordinate system so no the origin of
the coordinate system shouldn't in any
way be associated with um an observer in
any particular uh relationship
tara lumagi says are there mathematical
objections to super determinism as
opposed to just philosophical ones so
tara i'm going to apologize ahead of
time um i'm going to use your question
not really to answer it but to make a
point and uh the reason why i'm not
going to answer it is because i don't
know i don't really know what the
objections to super determinism are um
well i don't sorry i don't know if there
are mathematical ones in particular uh
there could be so i mean i imagine that
what you would mean by that is that
there's some inconsistency or some
mathematical hurdle or objection you
have to overcome to write down a fully
coherent and
consistent theory of super determinism
and maybe there's some obstacle to doing
that
and the reason why i don't know and i
don't i think it's okay for me not to
know is i'm not really and i don't
pretend to be an expert in
foundations of quantum mechanics as a
field
that might sound weird because i do
write a lot of papers in the foundations
of quantum mechanics but my angle within
that field is i think that the many
worlds interpretation is right
and i think that given that many worlds
interpretation is right there's still
lots of foundational questions left to
be answered about probabilities and
structure and you know all sorts of
ontological metaphysical and
epistemological questions there's a full
employment for a whole bunch of people
to work in that field
but
i'm not actually paying attention to the
discussion around other interpretations
of quantum mechanics or formulations
thereof and as i'm always very quick to
say
this is a bet that i make how to spend
my time and it could be completely wrong
i could be wrong i don't think i'm wrong
but it's very very possible i'm not
being absolute or certain about it but
we always have to do this in any
endeavor that involves spending time on
something intellectual trying to
understand how things go you have to
take some things as alright i'm going to
assume this is right and i'm going to
build on that
if every single academic whenever they
did a research project started with zero
assumptions and i'm not tara i'm not
saying that you're saying anything like
this i'm just giving my background uh
feeling about it but
you would you would never make any
progress right you if you always said
well let's not assume that we know what
the foundations of quantum mechanics are
that's a perfectly valid thing there are
people who are experts really in the
foundations of quantum mechanics as a
field and they can tell you the relative
differences between you know the pros
and cons of pilot wave theories and
epistemic theories and many worlds and
all these things super determinism i
just i just i'm not spending time trying
to do that
and uh you know i i don't make
assumptions about other things that
other people think are perfectly settled
you know i think that inflationary
cosmology might be right but i don't
think it's a 95 chance i think that the
chance that inflation is right is
substantially less than the chance that
many worlds is right many other
physicists would flip that and put it
the other way around but there you go
you have different people with different
opinions that's how you make progress so
i don't really know the answer to your
question tara sorry about that but i'm
letting you know why i don't know it
brad malt says
how is it possible that we were able to
observe the cosmic microwave background
it has had 13.4 billion years to travel
to us but with the expansion of space
aren't we more than 13.4 billion light
years away
uh so there's a simple answer to this
and a complicated answer the simple
answer is
the cosmic micro background doesn't come
from some location in space
it comes from everywhere in space right
it is what was happening everywhere in
the universe 380 000 years after the big
bang the universe was recombining the
electrons and protons were joining back
together so from everywhere
there was light being given off there
was radiation being given off and so if
you start today and trace light cones
backward it doesn't matter
where we are it doesn't matter how old
the universe is you will always reach a
point in the past that was glowing okay
at the recombination surface at the
surface of less scattering and that will
be sending light to us that we can
observe okay so that's the simple answer
but the reason why i want to answer this
question is because there is a more
subtle thing here about we being more
than 13.4 billion light years away
it's again it's relevant to this
question of our intuition newtonian
versus special relativity versus general
relativity
what do you what does it mean when you
say we're more than 13.4 billion light
years away when you're in an expanding
universe okay
what they mean by that people say that
and it's true and what they mean by it
is if you could extend a line
through a space-like surface of the
universe
you know in other words
through a surface of constant time since
the big bang
and you extend it out to
the point where the thing that we see in
the microwave background that that atom
that we see emitting at the microwave
background is now sitting that distance
along a space-like surface is more than
13.4 billion light years because the
universe has been expanding
at the moment when the light was emitted
that the
analogous distance between where we
would have been and where that atom was
actually emitting is much less than 13.4
billion light years away
so that's because there's not really any
good such thing as the distance
between two different observers in an
expanding universe there's different
distances that you can draw at different
times so you just have to like not think
that that quantity is important you know
you can measure it you can define you
can't even measure it sorry you can't
measure it but you can calculate what it
would be but kind of who cares so if you
have some reason to do that fine but
it's not a quantity that has any
essential meaning to us the distance
between two points on a space-like
surface defined in some particular way
okay
what matters in relativity are light
cones those really exist right you can
trace back the path of light and
everyone agrees on that that's not
relevant or relative to some observer
some coordinate system some slicing of
space time or anything like that and so
the the robust statement is starting
from us here and now trace backward in
time on light cones you will hit the
service of last scattering somewhere
that is the cosmic microwave background
that we observe
i'm going to group two questions
together one is from ken wolfe who says
if the simulation hypothesis posits that
we can never tell for certain that we
are not in a simulation
then is an assertion that either we are
or not just a statement of faith is
there anything that differentiates this
from statements of theology
and then noble gas says i was surprised
at how seriously chalmers in his recent
book takes the idea that we are living
in a simulation to me this idea seems to
recreate theism from a technological
standpoint do you see it this way as
well and as someone who stood against
theism does the growing acceptance of
the simulation idea in philosophy
circles bother you
so for those of you who don't know david
chalmers former mindscape guest recently
came out with a book reality plus where
he really really takes seriously the
idea that we could be living in a
simulation
and his major
goal in that book to to boil it's a
wonderful book i very much encourage you
buying it he's really just a terrific
writer and this is the the only i mean
of all the books he's written this is
the one that is most aimed at a
non-expert audience it's still full of
uh full strength philosophical arguments
but it doesn't assume a lot of the
linguistic background that experts would
have so it's very very readable
uh but his primary concern is not to
argue that we do live in a simulation
but to ask if we do
is what we're experiencing still real
right and as a good poetic naturalist
should do i don't think he's a poetic
naturalist but uh he says sure it's real
it means as real as anything else uh so
that's his main philosophical point that
he's trying to make okay
so both of these questions here from ken
and from noble are saying you know
doesn't this smack of theism and the
existence of god somehow and amusingly
if you read the book
chalmers says
i'm a really good atheist but this whole
simulation argument thing has made me
rethink that because in some sense if we
do live in the simulation it is like
having god it's not not the same kind of
god as the traditional theological
christian god but you know some higher
being that actually wrote us up in in
their little
computer simulation somehow um
so look uh
i
don't care if it is theological or not i
care if it's true right and the same
thing goes for theology i mean when when
you say that i am not theistic or i
don't like theology it's not that i sort
of have objections to contemplating the
possibility it's that i have
contemplated the possibility and i don't
think that the evidence supports that
hypothesis i'm perfectly happy with
other people also contemplating the
possibility and also i could be wrong
right new evidence could come in and
convince me that i'm wrong
um i think that i i do my hackles get
raised a little bit
whenever people compare a certain
idea to theology as a way of dismissing
it via guilt by association
right don't tell me whether something is
like theology tell me if it's right or
wrong you know what what is your
argument for or against it uh i once
gave a talk you can find it online it's
actually quite um gotten quite a few
views i gave a talk at an oxford
conference on philosophy
sorry in cosmology and theology i think
and uh so i gave the talk with the title
god is not a good theory and the whole
point of the talk was to say that we can
use all of the usual ways of evaluating
scientific theories about the world to
evaluate theism okay but there was a
typo in the conference program where my
talk was entitled god is not a theory
rather than god is not a good theory so
that ended up being the exact opposite
of my point my point is that theism the
simulation argument uh the multiverse
many worlds all of these things these
are perfectly legitimate scientific
ideas and you should judge them okay you
should not dismiss them
by using dirty words against them now
when it comes specifically to the
simulation argument
i try to do this i try to judge it as an
argument and i say
i try to be a good bayesian as i said
before bayesian epistemology i try to
say like what would i expect the
universe to look like if we lived in a
simulation and i try to compare it to
what the universe looks like and to me
the world that we observe around us does
not look like it would if we lived in a
simulation and this is the crucial
bayesian
point which is that it's it's not that
we look at the world and and again this
works this is exactly analogous to what
you would say about theology so in that
uh case the the
analogy is pretty good it's not that you
look at the world and say
can i explain this
by positing the existence of god or
positing the existence of a simulation
that's not the right move the right move
is to say
let's imagine
that we are comparing our expectations
from a purely naturalistic
self-contained universe versus a
theistic universe versus a simulation
what would i expect in each of those
cases so it's not sufficient to say i
can explain the world i want the theory
to explain what i do
see about the world to say that oh yes
this is exactly what i would have
expected and it's not what i would have
expected um as i said before the
resolution
in terms of pixels of our universe as
far as we know it's invented we have no
idea but it's certainly really really
really good way way better than it would
need to be for any simulation i see no
reason why
a simulator would want to cook up a
universe like ours that's not to say
they couldn't but if i'm being a good
bayesian what i'm supposed to ask is is
this what i expect and it is not
marian marcalli says i was thinking how
entropy is increasing but knowledge and
complexity seems to be increasing in
lockstep as a function of the
self-referential nature of the universe
so in computational terms the universe
and therefore humans can abstract
anything to create new computational
primitives or objects at infinitum
girdles and turing's observations can
therefore be considered the primary and
most important feature and not a bug at
all
so
i don't know whether girdles entering
observations and for that matter tarsky
i would throw him in there also i don't
know whether they should be features or
bugs they seem to be true facts about
mathematical logic
i'm not and then also not quite sure
uh when you say the universe and
therefore humans can abstract anything
to create new computational primitives
add infinitum
i'm not quite sure i'd want to go that
far either i mean it's the ad infinitum
that worries me there um
you know i do think and i've said this
before and i'm not an expert at it so
you shouldn't take my word for it but i
do
believe that uh there is this kind of
phase transition in reasoning in
cognitive capacity when
a brain or an information processing
system of some sort
gains gains enough capacity to be a
touring machine right to run any sort of
touring available
computer program that you might want to
run and as touring showed this is a lot
of computation essentially all the
computations you would ever want to do
there are limitations on what such
computations can do like the halting
problem you cannot prove that a certain
computer program will halt etc etc uh
but in the world of computations there's
a universality class that all computers
of a certain strength can do all the
computations now there's still
computations we can't do that's why i'm
i'm a little bit averse to the ad
infinitum at the end of your sentence
marion because we have finite resources
in space and in time and there's some
computations that are are literally
impossible to do like the halting
problem for example so
i think i know what you're saying but i
would just sort of edit that a little
bit with the ad infinitum there
and the other thing that i'm not quite
sure about is you say
entropy is increasing but knowledge and
complexity seem to be increasing in
lockstep that i just think is not true
if i take a book and i burn it
entropy is increased but knowledge is
not increased information you know good
old accessible information or complexity
has not increased in any way i think the
reality is that
entropy is increasing
complexity information kind of come and
go right you know there's pockets of
them and they can disappear and there's
there's no law of nature that says that
those things must increase in the same
way that entropy is going to increase so
i think the relationship there is a
little bit more delicate
and and nuanced and i think that you
know it's a little bit a little bit too
quick a little bit too glib to just
attach them to each other in some um
correspondence we need to think harder
about what the relationships are there
deepti amara surya says if you could
redesign the familiar format of the
undergraduate physics curriculum what
changes would you implement in the
content delivery and assessment
you know i don't i don't have a great
set of answers to this because i have
not been teaching uh undergraduate
physics for a while i taught one
undergraduate course in the last 15
years one quarter of one course so uh
one quarter in the sense of you know one
term in the quarter system that we have
at caltech
so i'm not an expert in all of the
details there you know i have certain
vague feelings
uh i do think that
as with any curriculum the curriculum
and physics tend to tends to lag behind
the times a little bit right um usually
the curriculum that we teach now is what
we really needed to be teaching 30 years
ago and not what we need to be teaching
now or 30 years in the future
there's the obvious example here is how
we teach quantum mechanics and that's
what's motivated me to think about
writing a quantum mechanics textbook
things like quantum information
decoherence entanglement
quantum computing are not mentioned in a
lot of undergraduate quantum textbooks
and there's no good reason for that
whereas we beat to death perturbation
theory and kleps gordon coefficients and
a whole bunch of things so that one
course i think would be improved by
quite a lot um the curriculum as a whole
you know i think that there's a lot of
certainly you know there's a lot of
smart undergraduates who are zooming
through
the curriculum that i had when i was an
undergraduate so they're like taking
string theory in their senior year or
whatever they've already taken quantum
field theory in their junior year which
seems dizzyingly fast to me um there's
no reason why general relativity should
not be part of the undergraduate
curriculum maybe not as a required
course but i would like to see it at
least be optional for everyone um
i did uh introduce undergraduate gr
course at university of chicago and that
was very very popular it's it's a very
very accessible subject for
undergraduates there's no reason not to
teach it i think the
the first year is always the crucial one
right and
i do it kind of depresses me that uh the
first year for many physics students has
a kind of weed out the week
feeling to it which i don't like um
maybe there's a better way to do it than
that but honestly i don't know what the
better way is given constraints of
resources and numbers and things like
that so i don't have any good
suggestions there
i do wish
that we could
um well i mean let me be specific about
this for physics majors
you have to just go through a lot of
drudgery
in the early days of your physics
curriculum right you need to learn the
incline planes and the electrical
circuits and that stuff that is
important and so it takes time before
you can get to the fun stuff of
relativity and quantum mechanics and
stat mech or or what have you
so i don't think you should actually
sort of put relativity or quantum
mechanics in the first semester of your
first undergraduate course but maybe
there is some way
to get
first-year undergraduates acquainted
with some of the research being done
in the department uh whatever that is
like little seminars or a one credit
course or something like that and a lot
of places do this i just think it should
be a regular thing let's make sure that
people are excited by the prospects of
doing this research themselves
for people who are not going to be
physics majors i think we do them a
dramatic disservice by very often just
offering them a course that is a
watered-down version of the course we
offer to physics majors right
if you're not going to be a physics
major then why not learn a little about
relativity in quantum mechanics you
don't need to learn about circuits and
inclined planes necessarily maybe a
little bit of that is useful too
but i think the purpose is completely
different if you're just trying to teach
people physics for the sake of physics
rather than
teaching them for the sake of a
prerequisite that will be useful when
they get to other physics later on um
i don't know those are not very uh
coherent thoughts but those are the
thoughts that i have right now
peter benham says is there one set of
quantum fields to house all the many
worlds or does each one have its own
i have no idea what the words to house
mean in this case fields live in space
time okay uh
space time
and forget about quantum mechanics for a
second we have space time and at every
point in space time there's a set of
fields and a value of the electron field
and the gluon field and the
gravitational field and so forth
in many worlds there's a set of worlds
and each world has its own space time
and its own quantum fields okay so the
fields are in the worlds not the other
way around and space time is in the
worlds not the other way around that's
why you can't say
where other worlds are located there is
no space in which they exist
um
[Music]
there's a separate question is whether
or not it's the same set of fields in
all many worlds let's put it this way in
the simplest versions of many worlds
without thinking too hard it's exactly
the same quantum fields and laws of
physics in all the worlds i do think it
is possible to have slightly more
sophisticated versions but i don't think
it's a necessary part of the theory
jim murphy says what's your view on how
pornography affects society especially
in its modern highly accessible form do
you see it as dangerous
well it's a tricky question i mean it's
dangerous but in the same way that many
things are dangerous pornography is
dangerous in the same way that driving
cars is dangerous or drinking alcohol is
dangerous
they can be misused and cause a lot of
deaths i think the number of deaths
caused by cars and alcohol is probably
way bigger than the number of deaths
caused by pornography and yet they are
perfectly allowed and and very easily
accessible
um i do think that i mean maybe i'm not
an expert on this the psychology here so
i probably should say nothing but my
vague feeling
is that there's some sense in which
pornography can be addictive in a way
that you know alcohol can be addictive
but again that doesn't mean we ban
alcohol we just try to give people
number one the freedom to choose
and hope that they make the right choice
uh and number two hope that they use it
responsibly
uh and number three some resources if
they do get addicted to it right i i
wish that society did all those things
anyway
it doesn't always measure up to those
hopes but that would be my hope uh do i
see it as dangerous it depends on what
you mean by dangerous i mean i guess
there's a danger
a potential danger in the sense that
people sort of become
immersed in pornography and lose
the ability to to connect with regular
human beings in the same way um that
doesn't sound like a huge worry to me
and even if it were i still think that
there is sort of an individual choice
that i would err on the side of but i'm
not an expert so maybe there's some you
know deeper worry there that uh i don't
know about um the other set of dangers
which has been well talked about is of
course um it
makes it gives people a sort of degraded
image of women you know when we talk
about pornography it's usually men
looking at pornography of women
and that can have all sorts of effects
on how they think about women more
generally and this was a bigger
deal and something that was talked about
a lot more i guess probably in the 80s
than it is today um but it's still out
there and you know i i think that this
is a case where it would be important to
separate
the
symptoms from the real problem you know
i think that if we lived in a society
where women were treated more equally
from the start then you could very
easily imagine
non-uh deleterious forms of pornography
they'll be perfectly okay in other words
i don't think it's the pornography
that is the trouble it's that the
problem is that we that women are not
treated equally or thought of that will
be in our society that's the real
fundamental problem so i would not you
know put a band-aid on pornography and
claim victory there i think that's not
really the way forward
saad ahmed says have you ever been taken
by feelings of nationalism or patriotism
in the past or now i suppose
you know i mean i guess probably no is
this short answer
if i'm trying to guess what you mean by
that i mean i might you know root for
the dream team the u.s basketball team
uh in the olympics when they when they
were the dream team back when michael
jordan and larry bird and magic johnson
were playing for them um these days they
don't care as much about the olympics
one way or the other but you know sports
and things like that are completely
harmless or
almost completely harmless versions of
nationalism or patriotism you know i
think that uh
the us is a big complicated country with
a big complicated history and i
my version of patriotism
is to both appreciate the good aspects
of its current existence and its history
and very much appreciate its bad aspects
as well uh i'm very much against
whitewashing
the bad aspects of our history you know
i think that teaching how
horrible we have treated the rest of the
world is really really important and i
think that's part of the ability to do
that to the scent there is such an
ability is part of what makes a country
strong you should do that and you know
different countries have different
uh success rates at doing that i think
the united states is kind of mediocre at
that you know the us does tend to
perceive itself the average american if
that's even a sensible concept
is way more sanguine about america doing
bad things to the rest of the world than
they should be either currently or in
the past
but i can still you know appreciate
the values that the united states was
founded on and by that i mean the sort
of aspirational values not the reality
of what was going on back in the 18th
century because that was obviously very
messy and compromised but i i i can
accept that and at the same time think
that the people who
started up the united states
were on to something good when they
thought that uh the authority of a
government comes from its people not
from god or from someone having more
power than anybody else
we had a long road to that is nowhere
near finished yet uh to actually achieve
that ideal um but i think that's a good
thing something that's perfectly okay to
be proud of realizing that we're not the
first we're not the best but it's
something we did right so you know i'm
not
out there uh
waving the flag or anything like that
but i think a nuanced view of the
history of a country uh is a is an
important thing you know there's this
this is not the united states so it's
not quite apropos but
there's this wonderful meme that has
gone around for years of
what
how people in the uk view the uk and how
people outside the uk view the uk and
inside it's like this cute little
bulldog puppy and outside it's like this
terrible ravenous wolf like the united
kingdom england and great britain uh
they've invaded everywhere right and you
know if you ask them they're like just
bringing civilization everywhere
shouldn't they be thankful
i don't think that
big powerful countries bringing
civilization elsewhere has really been a
successful
from the point of view of the people
whose civilization is apparently being
imposed upon them as the imposers would
like to believe so this is all very
complicated stuff i think that again
simplifying it is the one bad thing that
you can oversimplifying it is the one
big mistake you can make
justin bailey says i used to see you
quoted in new scientists often for
various cosmology related articles how
did you get on the list of scientists to
call do reporters just cold call you uh
yeah there's no
magic bullet or special procedure to get
called by reporters it depends on the
situation and it usually sort of
accumulates over time right
sometimes you meet reporters at
conferences uh aps meetings double aas
meetings triple a s meetings or what
have you sometimes reporters go to
meetings like that and meet scientists
and then get to know them
sometimes the scientist has done some
work that is associated with a press
release and therefore they get known
that way or sometimes the scientist just
has a public presence blogging twitter
these days
whatever writing popular articles
there's various ways that a journalist
might get to know the name of a
scientist and then the journalist is
going to very very naturally have their
favorite scientists to talk to
scientists are not all equally adept at
explaining science to a wider audience
or speaking in non-jargon terms or even
the slightly more subtle skill of
providing a juicy quote right a quote
that is both accurate but also makes
things sound exciting rather than boring
now ideally a journalist will try to
spread the wealth right they will try to
talk to various people different people
for different articles uh different
kinds of diversity along various axes
but you know life is short you don't
always get there sometimes you just want
that juicy quote and you go for the same
person over and over again
in a related question here scott lewicky
says i'm going to relate this even
though it's not obviously related
frequently in your episodes you will
reference a previous mindscape podcast
guest when talking to the current guest
there's often some great discussion that
comes from this comparing or contrasting
the views of more than one guest have
you considered inviting back two or more
previous guests and creating a panel
discussion that you could facilitate if
so which guest would you bring together
and what would be the theme so i've
considered things like that so but as
you'll notice
i have informally instituted a policy
where
i do not repeat guests other than myself
that's a special dispensation for solo
episodes right but other than that i
never have the same guest on twice and a
number of previous guests have asked to
come on in fact people who i think would
make great
repeat guests but uh this is a
something i thought about quite a bit
and i've decided that the value added by
with you know this goes back to the
previous question the value added just
by forcing myself
to spread out and not just have the
usual suspects over and over again is
more than the value added that i would
get by having a favorite set of guests
and and going back to them over and over
this is not to say that there are not
very real
benefits of having a favorite set of
guests going to them over and over again
um
there's a sort of institutional memory
that gets built up from previous
discussions you know ahead of time the
person is going to have good things to
say etc etc but i do think that you know
a lot of people do that right a lot of
podcasts have their favorite guests they
go back to again and again i do try to
be different try to differentiate in
some ways
and
part of the spirit of mindscape as i see
it is really about exploring the ideas
right it's not about our favorite set of
personalities to interact with and again
this makes it a slightly quirky thing so
if you want me to spin it this way
you the audience for mindscape are an
elite group
you uh are willing to listen to a bunch
of episodes that are driven not
primarily by
the fact that you've already heard of
the guest before i suspect that for most
people listening
many of the episodes most of the
episodes i don't know are with people
you've never heard of before but you
would like to
listen to this episode just because the
topic is good or even maybe the topic
doesn't naturally appeal to you but you
have a assumption that there's some
reason why i picked that person there
must be something worthwhile
and of course i usually do have reasons
why i pick the people they don't always
work out you know most of my guests i
think are very very good but there is
certainly a spectrum of success but you
got to do the experiment right you have
to try different things there's a
comfort to going to the same restaurant
every wednesday and ordering the same
thing but then you might miss some
things elsewhere on the menu or at other
restaurants and
given my own personal preferences i tend
to want to be more experimental and
given that plenty of other podcasts do
it differently this is one way to be
different so
um reluctantly in some cases i've stuck
with the policy of not inviting guests
back
now i i make no promises that i will
continue to stick to that policy
and
i mean part of it is also there's a rich
get richer kind of thing right you know
the kind of people you invite back or
people who are like smooth talkers who
are good on podcasts and those people
get to talk plenty of places they don't
really need mindscape all the time and
sometimes i have people on the podcast
who are less naturally good at talking
but still have interesting things to say
so i think it's important to get to
those people you know that no matter how
wonderful a person is and no matter how
much you love listening to them there
was always a time when you had never
heard of them before there was always a
first time when you heard of them so i
think that the
possibility that the next episode is
going to be some brilliant magical
person who you've never heard of before
is a big thing that i try to keep alive
which
would be less likely if i had the same
people over and over again um now that's
not exactly what you said i mean scott
you're asking about having panel
discussions with previous guests things
like that you know i've thought about
lots of things i've thought about having
a conference right where you get people
in
previous guests in the same place in the
real world back when we would get
together in the real world um
i guess most of minescape's existence
now has been in a pandemic hasn't it uh
some
maybe that's not exactly true but it's
got it's getting there
um
and i thought of having you know
different formats for different episodes
with different numbers of guests and
things like that you know it's all
number one it's more work
because as i said i have the current
system down to more or less a machine
that i can get it over with pretty
quickly uh there is a lot of you know
behind the scenes time that it takes to
schedule to get people microphones to
get the transcripts done all that stuff
and it becomes exponentially
more complicated when there's more than
one person at a time involved so i
haven't really come up with a great way
to expand the format
that would not be way more work for me
with any obvious tangible benefit if the
benefit were huge then maybe i would do
it but you know especially because many
of these are on
a remote right many of these
interviews and
having multiple guests is even harder
when you're doing things remotely you
know we don't see each other as well
it's harder to interrupt and to ask
questions in real time so
i'm not
leaning toward doing that at this time
but i do keep the possibility open and
i'm certainly open to suggestions about
how to be creative with the format
andrei dinu says you explain in the past
that the state of the universe could be
described by a vector in a hilbert space
the evolution of the universe is
equivalent to the trajectory of this
vector in hilbert's space however the
state of a system with variable number
of identical particles is described by a
vector in fox space which is the direct
sum of several hilbert spaces how is
this last space called and why do you
not refer to this space when you think
about the universe as a whole
there's a lot going on here this is a
technical level question but i think uh
it's interesting enough to the broader
audience that i thought it was worth
talking about the point is that
when you do quantum field theory one of
the reasons why quantum field theory is
so cool is because even though when you
quantize a single non-interacting field
what you get is a set of particles with
a definite number of particles or some
superpositions of different numbers of
particles but when you let the field
interact with itself or with others that
number of particles can change so
whenever you have a situation where
particles are created or destroyed
through interactions field theory is a
way to sort of summarize what's going on
there
and one way of thinking about that is to
construct what is called fox space which
is to say there's a part of hilbert's
space where there are no particles the
vacuum okay empty space then there is
the one particle hilbert space so you
excite the field just enough to have
exactly one particle and that particle
can be doing different things it has a
wave function it has all the different
infinite number of possible wave
functions then there's another part of
hilbert's base that has two particles
okay and all the way up then you add
those all together because the wave
function for the quantum field will be a
superposition of zero particles one
particle two particle etc and that sum
is called fox space fock after vladimir
fox the russian physicist and
mathematician so
two things to say here one is fox space
is still a hilbert space
it's not a different kind of thing it's
a particular kind of hilbert space that
you construct by adding together these
individual hilbert subspaces but it's
still hilbert space so it's still
perfectly okay to call it hilbert space
secondly
thinking of field theory in terms of
particles is not completely
comprehensive it doesn't always work it
works when you can think safely about
tiny perturbations in the field right
tiny fluctuations look like particles so
that generally refers to the
perturbative
regime of the particle of the field
theory where you can just start with the
vacuum and then perturb it by adding a
particle or two watching them interact
in more general circumstances like when
the higgs field just smoothly evolves
from zero to its expectation value in
empty space
you cannot easily describe that in terms
of particles at all so the fox based
description is just not very helpful so
fox base is a specific kind of hilbert
space that is only relevant in specific
circumstances it's not a more general
concept
jonathan goodson says when you were a
member of the world science symposium
world science festival symposium one
quantum mechanics the moderator asked
the panel will the scientific community
reach a consensus within the next 100
years as i recall the other participants
said yes but when it was your turn
you'll find the consensus will be
achieved within 50 years
what was your thinking giving that
response and was it anything more than
confidence in mwi and the ultimate
competency of your peers
i mean part of it just to be slightly
flippant about it is that 50 years is my
go-to amount of time to make predictions
because i will probably be dead
i'm not sure maybe i'll get lucky but uh
at least it's a period of time when i
could not be held responsible with
whether i was right or wrong so it's a
good number to pick but also yes i am
kind of optimistic that
we are making progress on the
foundations of quantum mechanics like i
said i particularly are i specifically
think that many worlds is going to be
the right answer but even if it's not i
still think we're making progress i
still think that we have
a lot more iq points worldwide trained
on the problem of understanding the
foundations of quantum mechanics than we
have in previous decades and i don't
think it's an intractable problem either
so i think that there will be a
consensus about it sooner rather than
later
david harrington asks a priority
question remember to those of you who
are new priority questions are questions
you're allowed to ask once in your life
and you can drop them into the amas on
patreon and i promise i will answer them
i don't promise i will give you a
satisfactory answer but i will
definitely answer them one way or the
other so choose your priority questions
wisely because you're on your honor to
only ask one ever in your life and david
says
i have since reading least mullen's book
on universes from black holes been
bugged by a simple question
where does the energy come from in
smallin's hypothesis a black hole of
only a few solar masses would create a
full-fledged universe where does all
that extra energy come from the short
answer is that the energy of the
universe is zero
at least in this model
this is just a fact of general
relativity that in a closed universe in
a universe whose spatial slices are
something like a sphere or a torus or
something like that
the total energy is zero which you can
roughly informally but not precisely
think about as saying that there is a
positive contribution from the energy of
matter from stuff you know matter
radiation dark energy what have you and
a negative contribution from the energy
of the gravitational field the curvature
of space-time
that's a rough informal thing i mean
really what you should think of is we're
talking about cosmology in the whole
universe there's no reason at all that
your intuitive notions of energy should
even apply in this case but at a formal
mathematical level there is a quantity
that is conserved in general relativity
which looks energy-like and for a closed
universe uh it is exactly zero so
more form even more formally than that
the point is that you can in general
relativity quantum gravity rather you
can imagine bubbling off
a baby universe as i've written about in
my paper with jennifer chen and alan
guth and eddie fary and others wrote
about years ago
um
in a way that costs exactly nothing
because it has zero conserved quantities
so not only zero energy total in this
universe but zero angular momentum zero
electric charge all of those things so
there's no obstacle
to having quantum processes that create
as many of these as you want that's sort
of the secret at the heart of the
mechanism that jennifer chen and i
proposed for making uh more and more
entropy in the universe if you can make
more and more universes each one of them
adds a little bit to the entropy of the
whole shebang you can just increase
entropy without bound
matt rappaport says it occurs to me that
the act of observing or measuring a
particle requires hitting that particle
with something like a photon and then
having the photon bounce back into a
detector i'm wondering if the act of
hitting the particle during an
observation might change the particle's
properties such as its momentum if you
wanted to measure the particle's
position with increasing accuracy you
would want to use photons with smaller
and smaller wavelengths thus higher and
higher energies
is this a reasonable way for a lay
person such as myself
to understand the heisenberg uncertainty
principle
well i kind of want to say yes and no
here um
if you just want sort of an intuitive
answer in a way that it kind of connects
with your newtonian feeling about the
world or your classical mechanics
feeling about the world
yes to measure the position of something
small requires a small wavelength
requires a lot of energy therefore
you're going to have to kick the
particle a little bit
but if you're a little bit more careful
if you're a little bit more trying to
understand at a deeper level that's not
the heisenberg uncertainty principle the
heisenberg uncertainty principle has
nothing to do with measurements or
observations i guess i shouldn't say
that it has implications for
measurements and observations but it's
not about
measurements and observations the
heisenberg uncertainty principle is a
feature of the states of particles the
states of any quantum system whether or
not they're observed
in quantum mechanics the momentum
is related to the position in a
complicated way because there is no such
thing as either momentum or position
there's a wave function momentum and
position are observables associated with
that wave function and they are what we
call complementary observables and what
that means is that if you have a wave
that is a wave function if you try to
compress that wave in space
in position okay so this very very
carefully localized around some
particular point in space
then the complementary feature of it the
momentum gets spread out all over the
place so if you have a sine wave for
position wave function you will have a
delta function for momentum and vice
versa if you have a delta function for
position you have a sine wave for
momentum and if you have a bell curve
something that is spread out but only a
little bit then you can have that for
both at once these are all statements
about the wave function of the particle
and how it has to be
it's nothing to do with measurements
again it has implications for
measurements but it's not about
measurements so another way of thinking
about it at a much simpler level is just
think about a two-dimensional hilbert
space so forget about
position and momentum think about spin
right think about the spin in the
z-direction
of some particle it could be spin up or
spin down
now the tricky thing is you naturally
think of spin up as pointing vertically
up and spin down is pointing vertically
down but in hilbert's phase in the space
of all possible quantum wave functions
these two possibilities are
perpendicular you are either spin up or
spin down or you're some combination but
they're orthogonal to each other so
you'd make a plot of spin up
horizontally and spin down vertically or
something like that and that's all with
respect to the z direction and then if
you ask about spin in the x direction or
y which is let's pick one pick x
the x spin can be figured out in terms
of the z spin
but the way to figure it out is that the
axes are rotated by 45 degrees okay so
the spin up with respect to x-axis
is tilted at 45 degrees with respect to
spin up and spin down in the z-axis so
what this means is
if a particle has a spin that is in a
pure state of z spin
so it's either pure spin up or pure spin
down
it can't also be in a pure state of
x spin it's going to be an equal
combination an equal superposition of
spin up and spin down in the x direction
just because the axes are tilted with
respect to each other it's a
mathematical fact not
related to how we observe it or anything
like that that's the uncertainty
principle
samuel cohn says
i've heard you mentioned that the helper
space of the universe is large but
finite dimensional how do you reconcile
this with the commutation relation
between the momentum and position
operators it's an elementary exercise
that in a finite dimensional space if
the commutator of two operators is a
multiple of the identity then the
commutator is zero uh yeah that's true
and just to be super duper careful here
when i say
things like the hilbert space of the
universe's finite dimensional that's you
know
a speculation we don't know that for
sure okay we are saying that uh we have
good reason to believe that the hilbert
space of our observable part of the
universe is finite dimensional it's not
an absolute statement that we know the
answer to um
but as you might guess
if you have a finite dimensional hilbert
space that dimensionality is really
really big like 10 to the 10 to the 120
dimensions
that's pretty close to infinity for a
lot of local purposes so you would be
very very surprised if some
you know persnickety mathematical fact
that distinguished between finite and
infant dimensional hilbert spaces really
mattered and indeed in a finite
dimensional hilbert space you can
construct analogs of position and
momentum that are not exactly the same
but they have the same kind of
commutator the position and momentum do
and then you can take a limit as that
number becomes really really big the
dimensionality of hilbert's space they
become more and more like position and
momentum so in fact i did this with
ashmit singh who was a student here at
caltech we wrote a paper on doing
exactly this and i will read you the
title of the paper modeling position and
momentum in finite dimensional hilbert
spaces via generalized paly operators
pretty good huh you asked a question
that i actually wrote a paper about so
you can go to the uh archive and look
for that paper modeling position
momentum in finite dimensional helper
spaces via generalized pali operators so
it can be done i mean obviously i
presume that you know a little physics
here if you're asking questions like
that so you should be able to read the
paper and see what we have to say it was
just a it was it came out in uh what
2020 not too long not too long ago so
there you go
anonymous says
do you have any advice for casually
talking about academic or intellectual
interests and hobbies without coming
across as bragging or trying to act
superior how would you describe the
middle way between heavily editing
yourself to make people comfortable on
one extreme versus refusing a
responsibility to read the room on a
basic level on the other extreme
so i just want to
make this question a bit more general
because i think that it's a question
that's nothing to do with
intellectual interests or hobbies or
acting superior uh it's just a general
question about how do you talk about
things you care about
that the rest of the room may or may not
okay if those things happen to be
intellectual or whatever that's great
and if they're not that's also great you
know maybe you like
uh watching the rodeo maybe you like uh
knitting okay and maybe no one else who
you're talking to does or maybe they do
and you don't know it right so i think
that it's no different than if you like
knitting versus if you like quantum
mechanics perfectly honestly the ways in
which you might get a negative reaction
differ in details
if you like knitting and someone is uh
and the whole room is full of macho
people who would look down upon that
they might be condescending whereas if
it's a full of a bunch of people who are
anti-intellectual and you like quantum
mechanics then you might get uh
defensiveness kind of reaction but the
general strategy is the same namely
on the one hand you should
simultaneously be
proud of your interests you should not
apologize for them you should be able to
express enthusiasm for things you're
enthusiastic about and at the same time
recognize that if other people aren't
interested then this just isn't the room
to talk about that you shouldn't force
it on them whether it's knitting or
quantum mechanics okay
some people are going to be interested
some are not try to discover who those
people are by you know maybe mentioning
that you're kind of interested in this
stuff and if they're just not then move
on to something else and if you're
unable
to talk to them about other things if
you're unable to find any overlap
between what you're interested in what
they're interested in either then
there's some issue with you or more
likely you're just in the wrong room and
you should go to a room where you can
talk about stuff that you both agree are
interesting
james maddox says in the standard model
what is a mixing angle they seem to
determine strength of interactions and
relate closely to symmetry and
unification but do they have a physical
interpretation
yeah they do have a physical
interpretation so um
i mean i don't want to spend too much
time because again this is a technical
physics question but basically think
about quarks okay you have the
positively charged quarks uh up charm
and top i might i may or may not get
this right which is positive energy
negative up charm top and then uh down
strange and bottom the negatively
charged quarks okay and roughly they're
in pairs right up and down are a pair
charm and strange are a pair top and
bottom are a pair what does that mean
that means that the up quark when it
interacts when either you know
transforms when it gives off a w boson
so it changes its identity usually the
up quark is going to change into a down
and the down is going to change into it
up and vice versa but not all the time
so the up quark is actually going to
change into some linear combination
of
all the negatively charged quarks so you
have an up quark which is charged plus
two-thirds it gives off
a uh w plus right a positively charged w
boson so it converts into a minus
one-third charged quark but it's not
purely a down quark it's a combination
of up sorry of down
strange and bottom there you go and that
which combination it is that's what the
mixing angle is telling you this the
precise amount um by which you get these
different combinations same thing is
true with neutrinos and leptons and so
forth roughly speaking this is all just
saying that
there are different properties that
quantum fields have and the properties
don't always march in lockstep so in the
neutrino world for example the important
fact is that there are
mass states okay there are uh well i
should say the other way around you may
have heard that in the world of
neutrinos there are electron neutrinos
muon neutrinos and tau neutrinos and
what that means is
uh these numbers are conserved so when a
uh tau lepton decays it's going to have
to give off a tau neutrino and then
maybe like a muon and an anti-muon or
something like that okay no that can't
be right
to conserve charge if a tau decays it
will have to spit off a mu a muon and
then a an anti-mu neutrino so muon
number is conserved plus a tau neutrino
so tau number is conserved
okay
but
what it turns out to be the case is that
the states of definite mass are not
purely
electron neutrinos muon neutrinos or tau
neutrinos they're mixed together and
figuring out what exactly that mixture
is is a very high priority thing that
we're trying to do in the world of
neutrino physics right now jake mcneil
says scott aaronson suggested that
during a lecture i attended that quantum
computing might be a useful method of
teaching core concepts of quantum
mechanics do you think that might be a
good approach to introducing quantum
mechanics especially for those with more
of a computer science background rather
than a math and physics background
you know it could be um
my brain is is thinking these days about
teaching physics students quantum
mechanics so that's what i know and care
the most about
for computer science students it might
be different i mean there is a sense in
which
quantum computing is a generalization of
classical computing you replace bits
with qubits
and and not gates etc with their quantum
gate equivalents and so forth and you
have this whole new thing which is that
states can be in superpositions and then
you have to read out the uh outcome with
a measurement that collapses the wave
function but otherwise it is a
generalization of the of the whole idea
of bits and computing so you could teach
things that way sure absolutely you're
never going to get to the hydrogen atom
that way though
you're never going to get to the simple
harmonic oscillator or quantum tunneling
or a whole bunch of other interesting
phenomena
so i think you know honestly
my current thinking is to be hybrid
about it you know given that i am
interested in how to teach
physics majors i i take that they come
into it knowing some classical mechanics
they know a little bit about positions
and velocities or momenta of particles
right that's how they're trained to
think a ball rolling around in a
potential on an inclined plane
and the usual traditional way of doing
quantum
pedagogy is to take that classical
system and quantize it to replace
positions and momenta with wave
functions and go on from there
i think that's fine i think it's a good
thing to do but you in instantly get
into
difficulties released sticky wickets
mathematically speaking because the
hilbert space of a single particle is
infinite dimensional and infinity is
harder than two
a qubit has a two-dimensional hilbert
space which is a lot easier to deal with
so conceptually
qubits are a lot easier
way to introduce quantum mechanics the
problem with them is they don't connect
with anything you've heard of in
classical mechanics there's no equation
of motion for a qubit classically okay
so i think you can do both i think you
can say
here's a classical particle let's
quantize it oh we get a wave function oh
we notice that wave functions are
vectors in a hilbert space oh we notice
that there are much smaller hilbert
spaces than that like two dimensional
hilbert spaces and then use that
two-dimensional qubit language to
introduce a lot of the concepts of
quantum mechanics and just do both
that's what i would like to do i would
like to do both
anonymous different these are all
different anonymouses there's not one
anonymous asking many questions
anonymous says the collection of
homeostatic chemical processes we call
life self-propagate in the direction of
the arrow of time because this is the
direction where entropy increases the
intelligent computational systems based
on these chemical processes we call our
minds thus experience the arrow of time
as a whole the entropy of the universe
increases but there exists regions where
entropy decreases could there be
homeostatic chemical processes that
propagate in the reverse direction in
these regions life in the reverse
direction
so no the answer is no
but it's a little bit tricky to explain
why and in fact this might very well be
something where i just don't understand
it well enough to give you uh the
simplest answer here but
let me explain to you why i'm quite
confident that that is the right answer
um
the second law of thermodynamics applies
when you have a closed system and you
say a closed system that starts in a
state of low entropy will with
enormously large probability evolve to
states of higher entropy okay
there are ways
to have systems spontaneously decrease
in entropy
namely they're not closed systems right
they're open systems so my favorite
example you put a bottle of champagne in
the refrigerator
and it will lower its temperature and if
you calculate the entropy afterward it
has a lower entropy just because it's
lowered its temperature that counts as
lowering its entropy okay
but the point is that even though we say
and it is true we correctly say that the
arrow of time is due to the fact that
entropy is increasing
that little glib motto
slides over some important details okay
so the details matter and actually this
came through a little bit
in the podcast with david wallace we
were talking about the arrow of time
that you know sure entropy is increasing
but there's more to it than that entropy
is increasing in a particular way so
think of it this way so i mean roughly
what i want to say just to get to the
answer to the question is
if i put something in a refrigerator its
entropy will go down because it's in a
closed system but there's no it's an
open system sorry
there's no sense
in which the arrow of time is reversed
inside that um bottle of champagne and
the way that you can see this is uh you
know think about a very typical thing
that we use to illustrate the increase
of entropy um if you have a cup of warm
water and you put an ice cube in it the
ice cube melts and you get a cup of cool
water and entropy is increased along the
way okay but if you take that cool water
and now you put it into a refrigerator
it's not gonna it will lower an entropy
if if its coolness is not quite as cool
as the refrigerator it will lose it will
radiate photons and heat out to its
environment its entropy will go down but
it will not spontaneously form into an
ice cube plus a glass of warm water just
from sitting in the refrigerator the
whole thing is just going to cool down
okay
so there are differences in the details
of the way in which entropy increases or
decreases in a closed system naturally
increasing entropy versus an open system
leaking entropy out into the world
around it so and there's details there
upon details that i'm not going to get
into but the short answer is you don't
expect a reversed arrow of time in an
open system that is going downward in
entropy
jim watson says regarding cosmic
redshift due to expanding space time
where does the energy loss from the
photon go as it is redshifted uh two
answers to this depending on what level
you care about one answer is energy is
not conserved
in an expanding universe the total
energy of stuff
of matter and radiation etc is not a
constant number because space time is
changing underneath it okay i wrote a
whole blog post about this if you go and
google energy is not conserved you'll
probably get my blog post about this
the longer answer which i have to give
usually i stop there but the longer
answer because i have to give it now
because i've already mentioned that in
general relativity there is a conserved
energy that includes the energy of the
gravitational field okay so the energy
that is not conserved is just the energy
of the stuff inside space-time if you
try to
attach an energy to space-time itself
you can do that it's tricky there's
details there's mathematical subtleties
but you can do it and that number is
conserved okay so in that way of
thinking about energy because there's no
single way of doing it there are
different ways of doing it um in that
way what you would say is that there is
a transfer of energy
from space-time
between space-time and the photons if
it's photons they lose energy which is
absorbed by space-time if it's dark
energy you know dark energy increases
its total amount of energy in a certain
region of space as the universe
increases so energy can either go up or
down in stuff and in either case
space-time responds appropriately
rue phillips says david chalmers refers
to you in his new book reality plus he
believes we are in a pure simulation his
credence comes from statistical analysis
if it is possible for someone in our
universe to create a pure simulation
then it will be much more likely that we
are sims because it is much easier to
create billions of sim worlds than the
universe to create billions of physical
worlds with life what are your credences
on these concepts and what if anything
is chalmers neglecting in his argument
for us probably being sims
you know i don't i'm not going to give a
full
account of this because i think these
are subtle issues but what i really
think is that people tend to misuse
anthropic reasoning in this case and
this is something you know i don't be
too mealy-mouthed about it but i'm not
completely sure that my opinion is the
right one but it is my tentative way of
thinking right now um
the as i said before the
simulation argument
really there's a there's a step you know
if you take the simulation argument to
just say maybe we live in a simulation
then that's fine that's completely true
maybe we do but if you take it to say we
probably live in a simulation well then
you're assuming some measure right on
the space of who we could be
and people tend to use some kind of
principle of mediocrity or typicality or
whatever you want to call it you know we
are randomly selected from the set of
all possible
people intelligent beings in the
universe and i think that's just wrong i
don't think you should assume that we
are randomly selected from the set of
all people in the universe there's many
ways in which i am not randomly selected
from the set of all intelligent
observers even here on earth much less
in the whole universe so i think that
step just doesn't work uh what i would
rather do as i said before is to ask the
question what would the universe look
like if it were a simulation and i don't
think it look it would look much like
our actual universe does
to be a little bit more clear about that
typicality point
um
here's the way that i like to put it i'm
borrowing language from other people and
i forget who it is so i can't give
credit sorry about that but
it seems humble when you say i think
that i'm just a typical observer in the
universe right that's why it's literally
sometimes called the principle of
mediocrity
but you don't know
what a typical person in the universe
looks like you don't know what the space
of all possible observers in simulations
and elsewhere in space or whatever you
have no idea right
so really
when you're assuming that you are just a
typical observer you're actually
assuming the typical observers are like
you
and that's not humble at all that's sort
of maximally arrogant you're assuming
that you can infer some facts about all
the observers in the universe just on
the basis of your local parochial
experience of the world so i think
that's wildly unwarranted by anything
that we know about reason or logic or
experience or anything like that
i do think there are ways to to still
make anthropic like arguments
um i think that it's okay
to say that
models of cosmology that make it more
likely that observers like us would
exist observers exactly like us so
forget about typicality observers
exactly like you okay
models of cosmology that make it more
probable that a person exactly like you
would come into being
should be preferred in a bayesian sense
over models that have low probability of
you coming into being that's the kind of
thing that i think is okay to say
without making any assumptions about
your typicality in the cosmos
joe asks have you ever used linux on a
desktop laptop or server if so what did
you think of it
so uh yeah i did when i was at the
university of chicago for several years
i had a linux desktop machine um it was
fine you know i've not
my attitude towards these things
operating systems and so forth is
there's no right or wrong i mean some
are better than others for different
purposes but different users and
different sets of needs are going to
be better served by different operating
systems so
if you're really into it if you're
really into operating your
operating system getting into the guts
of it and changing things around to
please your uh whims then linux is great
and you can tinker with it if you just
wanted to work and forget about it if
your intellectual energies are focused
elsewhere then linux is not the
operating system for you so i'm very
happy with the mac these days i don't
love being you know beholden to the mac
ecosystem overall but the things that
they do are good enough for me
that it works fine and there is a cost
in switching back
so you know the ipad
iphone
macbook pro
combined system works quite well for my
own needs and so i have no motivation to
contemplate switching
jeff b says as i listen to your
interviews with guests i'm always
impressed by your ability to come up
with questions that cut to the heart of
a topic do you believe this is something
that you were naturally talented at or
was it a skill that took practice well
thank you jeff for the nice compliment
like i said i'm not above uh including
questions here that involve the uh uh
compliments that to begin with um so i'm
not sure though to be to be super duper
honest here i'm not sure
that i have a special ability to come up
with questions that cut to the heart of
a topic what i do think is that there's
a simple feature of mindscape which is
that it's just me
right i am the one
choosing the guests booking them
interviewing them whatever and my
motivation for doing it is not primarily
greed or fame it's because i'm
interested in what these people have to
say that is literally my primary
motivation i started the podcast because
i wanted to talk to these people and
hear what they had to say learn from
them so i think that gives me a leg up
like i'm not a professional interviewer
who's handed a guest and some talking
points and asked to talk about them if
i'm inviting them on the podcast there's
something that they know that i would
like to know
so
i'm just being you know
sincere in my questioning because i'm
actually trying to get at what it is
they have to offer
there's one you know aspect that may or
may not be relevant here which is that
you do get trained as a scientist and
not just as a scientist but as an
academic more broadly um you get trained
to
understand things in such a way
that you could do research on them right
you know it's one thing to be handed a
book or a paper and say read it it's
another thing to be handed a book or
paper and say read it and there will be
a test on it okay so you're going to be
a little bit more careful reading it if
there's going to be a test
it's a whole nother thing to be handed a
book or paper and say read it
and then do your own research and write
a follow-up paper or book right that's
just a whole other level of
understanding and that's just what
you're trained to do
as a professional academic so i do try
to understand things in such a way that
i could afterwards i mean it's certainly
not true for all the podcasts i do that
i could then go off and do research in
these areas but it's the beginning of a
start
to understanding things well enough to
be able to do that so i'm not going to
be satisfied with you know words that
sound like i understand it i really need
to understand it well enough to think
that i could sort of use the ideas
myself at a research level uh it's not
true as i just said
that i could actually start doing
research but it's the beginning of that
process
patrick hall says you've spoken
extensively on the importance of
increasing interdisciplinary projects
between philosophy and theoretical
physics what branch of philosophy do you
think can benefit the most from
collaborating with theoretical physics
do you think the problems of metaphysics
can be solved with theoretical physics
um
i think this is like this like kind of a
hodgepodge i guess i mean i don't have a
systematic theory of what kinds of
philosophy can benefit from physics or
vice versa but there's a general kind of
obvious
set of ideas right i mean i do think
that philosophy is continuous with
physics they're not really separate
things they're both attempts to
understand the world and probably you
know you can throw in mathematics and a
bunch of other things that are in some
sense continuous it's we human beings
especially university administrators who
end up drawing these bright lines
between these different fields but if
there's a philosopher thinking about
what is the correct foundation
formulation of quantum mechanics and
there's a physicist thinking about what
is the correct formulation of quantum
mechanics they're doing the same thing
they're asking the same question okay
whatever department they might be in so
the kinds of problems that i forget i
won't necessarily
accurately answer your question but the
kinds of problems that i think are most
interesting at this intersection
are um
you know questions where our physics
knowledge needs clarification
okay so it's not just we need more data
but we need more clarity of thought
and there's plenty of ideas like that in
cosmology in quantum mechanics in
statistical mechanics and entropy and so
forth
that's that's like sort of i'm answering
the inverse question what can
physics ask for philosophy um what
philosophy can get from physics is more
like
well two things one is
they can be inspired by discoveries in
physics right like it's easy
it's too easy in certain areas of
philosophy to sort of lazily think that
features of the world you're familiar
with are necessary right
there's an argument about whether
emanuel kant thought that it was
necessary that space had three
dimensions
so he wasn't always clear so it's not
it's not obvious what he thought
but it's not necessary in any logical or
mathematical or physical sense that
space had to have three dimensions it's
a feature of our world so
even the existence of space itself
is something where i think a lot of
philosophers just take for granted and
you will hear them say that we couldn't
have you know i don't know uh
interactions or structure or memories
without spatial locality which i think
is obviously not true because i don't
think that spatial locality is
fundamental so that's an area where you
can really learn something from
listening to the physicists i think
and finally you can just be inspired in
the sense of
being given new questions to ask right i
mean
philosophers invent things like the
sleeping beauty problem
or other thought experiment kinds of
things uh and physicists come up with
real questions about boltzmann brains
and the the multiverse and you might
think those are very speculative but
they were not invented to be cool
philosophy puzzles they were invented
because they might actually apply to the
world and so like those new puzzles that
come in uh are directly germane to
metaphysical questions i mean you read
david lewis
uh and a lot of the stuff that he did is
pretty directly resonant with modern
physics even though he wasn't pretending
to actually do modern physics himself
rob f says as a layperson it seems
strange to me that the square root of -1
is of such fundamental importance to
quantum physics and by extension to
nature can you help me understand why
this imaginary number is of such
importance versus any other type of
number
i do think that uh there's kind of two
levels of answering this question
there's sort of the math level and the
physics level the math level is why were
you ever motivated to invent imaginary
numbers in the first place
and that i think that's very natural
answer coming just from the natural
progression of mathematics toward
greater
generality and abstraction right like if
you have an equation
like two plus three equals five
that's good you can understand that no
no issues and then you try to generalize
it so you say well what if x plus three
equals five right i'm not gonna tell you
what x is but then you can solve and you
can figure out you can solve that
equation x must equal two okay and
you're still very happy this is you know
this we're talking about three thousand
years ago you could still have had that
conversation
but then some says okay wiseguy what
about if
x plus three equals one
what are you going to do then and you
can say well you know what are we going
to do you're going to invent negative
numbers and i know that now we just take
those for granted but back in the day
that was a big deal you would say if x
plus three
sorry yeah x plus one equals five then x
has to equal
if you say x plus three equals one then
x has to equal minus two and you can
sort of intuit your way into that right
like there are you could have money or
you could have debts so debts are kind
of like negative money and imaginary
numbers are invented the same way you
say x squared equals 4
cool so x could be plus x could be plus
2 or minus 2.
but what if x squared equals minus 4
well you could just say there's no
solutions that's okay but maybe you like
the idea that every time you have an
equation with x squared in it
anytime you have a quadratic equation
there are two solutions maybe you like
that idea that's tricky because if x
squared equals zero the only solution is
zero but then you talk yourself into
thinking that you have zero two
different times
and more generally if you have x squared
equals minus four you could say that x
equals plus or minus 2 times the square
root of minus 1 2 times i so you invent
imaginary numbers that way
and that might be just you know
not very useful mathematical abstraction
if it weren't so useful right so that's
the second level of the answer to your
question why does this mathematical
construction find so many uses in
physics
and
that's a more tricky one because
you never need imaginary numbers you
never absolutely absolutely need
imaginary numbers you could always just
replace
any discussion of imaginary numbers with
separate discussions of their real parts
and their imaginary parts right you're
allowed to do that it's just much less
convenient so the question becomes why
is it convenient
to talk in the language of imaginary
numbers so i'm going to i'm going to try
to give you an answer
we'll see whether it actually works or
not so here's my attempted answer think
of the double slit experiment okay think
of a electron wave function it's a wave
it's passing through two slits and on
the other side it interferes
so what are the features
physically that you want to have happen
and forget about observations and
decoherence and all that stuff we're
just thinking the simple wave goes
through two slits and get an
interference pattern on the other side
so one thing is
it's clearly got a wave right it can't
be particles if you're getting
interference pattern on the other side
there needs to be
a contribution to what you're seeing on
the other side which is partly a
positive part and partly a negative part
so they can some places cancel out
that's what it means to get an
interference pattern so that's why waves
are the natural place to look the wave
be up or down it could be positive or
negative
so you might think okay i'm going to
invent something called the wave
function it's going to be real valued
but it could be positive or negative
but then you say well if i observe the
particle somewhere along the way
okay
then i need a probability of observing
it and for various reasons you want that
probability to look like the wave
function squared okay
if the wave function is a real number
and the probability of observing it is
the wave function squared
and that wave goes up and down right so
it's positive then 0 and negative and 0
and positive etc
that means that the probability of
finding the particle at all
seems to be oscillating
between zero and one that's not what you
want you want the probability of the
particle being somewhere just to be one
all the time
so this is a job for imaginary numbers
or for complex numbers more generally if
you say that the wave function squared
equals one i mean it's really the
integral of the wave function squared
but hopefully you know what i mean uh if
the wave function squared overall has to
equal one but you also want it to go up
and down and be able to interfere
that's what complex numbers can do
because it's not really going between
positive and negative it's circling
around with constant magnitude in the
complex plane
okay that's an attempt i don't know if
that attempt worked that's an attempt uh
to explain how negative numbers become
or imaginary numbers become very very
convenient in real world physics
situations
anonymous says what are your thoughts on
the current graduate student employment
crisis
as an undergraduate student i was
blissfully unaware of the extreme number
of steps one has to take
and roadblocks that are in the way when
one wants to work as a phd scientist
grad school postdoc little no control
over the final location
does the academy have a responsibility
to make prospective students aware of
what they're likely walking into even
though it doesn't benefit the academy
are there any creative solutions you've
thought of besides moving the bottleneck
from getting a job to getting into grad
school
i do think that we absolutely have a
responsibility to make prospective
students aware and i try very hard to do
it every student who is either
a prospective student or one who has
arrived and wants to work with me we
have the talk
and the talk involves saying you know
the odds are against you you get a phd
from the best place in the world and the
odds of getting uh becoming a tenured
professor are still small well maybe one
in four i don't know that's the number i
heard once in my life and i think that's
you know in the right ballpark ballpark
it's not one percent but it's not 90
either somewhere in between
um
i think we do need to let people know
and then let people choose whether or
not they want to do it anyway
i don't think the solution is to just
let fewer people get phds for lots of
reasons one thing is there's more
reasons to get a phd than just to become
a tenured professor somewhere getting a
phd is a useful thing
it's education that it's a degree okay
you can
become a smarter better thinker by
getting a phd and so it's not like
you've completely wasted your time if
you get a phd and then don't end up
being a professor
um
but i do think you should make that
decision yourself right so if we
i mean think about it this way if the
graduate schools just stop taking as
many students that means the graduate
schools are deciding for
all those people they're rejecting that
they shouldn't get a phd because maybe
they won't get a job i don't think that
should be the graduate school's decision
i think that should be the student's
decision they should make the decision
with all the information they can
possibly have but it should be their
decision to make um
i mean the overall problem
honestly is just not solvable if you if
you define the overall problem as there
are more people who would like to be
tenured professors than there are
tenured professorships right that's just
a feature of the
uh arrangement of society and the way
that we distribute our wealth and and
things like that okay that's not going
away anytime soon and to sort of
conflate that fact with some
statement about graduate school
admissions is a mistake there's a lot
more people who want to be professional
basketball players than there are room
for professional basketball players i
think that's not going away any time
soon there is one tweak i would make to
the system that i think is pretty
obvious which is not we should have
fewer grad students but that we should
have fewer postdocs you know as you say
in in fields like theoretical physics
anyway you spend five years getting a
phd
and then you get a postdoc which lasts
for three years
just doing research trying to buff up
your
resume your list of publications you can
apply for faculty jobs and these days
regularly people get two or three or
even more postdocs
and that's much less
defensible i think as a system right
a phd is an education it's a you're in
school you're getting a degree
postdocs are just you know sort of
training programs for researchers and
if you
spend five years getting a phd and then
six or seven or eight years as a postdoc
uh it's hard to then switch into a
completely different field
so i actually think this was you know i
give credit to kim body who is a
graduate student of mine when she first
applied for post docs she said i wish
there were fewer post-docs out there
uh because of exactly this reasoning and
i'd never thought of it before and she's
exactly right she actually made it she's
a professor now at the university of
texas so congratulations to kim but i
get the logic you know um professors
love postdocs
because they're trained they can do
research they help make professors
really really productive i'm much less
convinced that it's good for the
postdocs themselves it's a small tweak
that's what i would do i provide more
funding uh in the in the world of grant
funding and and institutional funding i
would put more of it to supporting grad
students less of it to supporting
postdocs even though i like having
postdocs around they're pretty awesome
anonymous says priority question
would it be possible to calculate the
minimum size the universe would have
assuming it's infinite to have all
possible interactions take place this
would be assuming all possible outcomes
are realized in many worlds um so
there's always a danger with priority
questions namely i have no idea how to
answer this question sorry about that um
i don't even know what it means to have
all possible interactions i literally
don't know what that means is that all
possible interactions between two
particles at a time or all possible
configurations of all particles and i
have no idea how that is associated with
the size of the universe
at all and furthermore i don't know how
many the interactions there are or
anything like that sorry about that i
just have zero idea how to answer this
question i don't think there's any to
try to be a little bit more um
constructive i don't think there's any
relationship between the number of
possible interactions and the minimum
size of the universe at all
but i don't know i might be wrong
because that seems to depend on features
of the laws of physics that i don't
know the answer to
sid huff says
on quora recently someone asked why
gravity has been so difficult for
science to reconcile with quantum theory
victor taut the physicist who often
responds to questions such as this
referred to semi-classical gravity while
he called semi-classical gravity an ugly
clutch he also noted that in all regimes
successful to us semi-classical gravity
provides answers that agree with
experiment what exactly is
semi-classical gravity is it a step
forward towards solving the problem of
quantum gravity uh yeah semi-classical
gravity is just
gravity when you quantize it but don't
push it too far okay so when i talk
about the core theory
the core theory includes both the
standard model of particle physics and
quantum gravity
but that quantum gravity is restricted
to weak field gravitation you can just
take the ordinary classical dynamics of
general relativity and turn the crank on
quantizing it where that breaks down is
where you go to higher order
interactions with gravitons running
around loops and so forth and even more
importantly in black holes or cosmology
singularities the big bang stuff like
that but okay don't include that stuff
if you want to know why the earth goes
around the sun or why apples fall from
trees you can use you can quantize
gravity in this weak field not very
dramatic regime perfectly well and
that's semi-classical gravity the
problem is no it is not a step forward
towards solving the problems because all
the problems are in the regimes where
semi-classical gravity doesn't really
apply cooper says i've heard david
chalmers and other proponents of the
hard problem of consciousness completely
dismiss emergence as a viable answer to
consciousness
in fact this dismissal appears to be one
of their primary arguments against
physicalism however it's not as if we
have finished the work to
comprehensively describe every element
in the emergent ladder between quantum
field theory and say a chair
and yet i don't hear philosophers
fretting about what it's like to be a
chair do you think there is hypocrisy
here in the philosopher's attitude
towards emergence
no i don't think it's uh hypocritical i
don't agree with it either so it seems
strange for me to defend the formulation
of the hard problem of consciousness but
it's it is an argument that makes sense
it may not be right but it's not
cheating in any way the argument is
supposed to be the whole point of
drawing the distinction between the hard
problem of consciousness and the easy
problems is that the hard problem is
supposed to be a different kind of
problem than describing a chair or
something like that okay so of course
you're correct that we've not described
all the
levels in between quantum field theory
and chairs but
it seems that all of those levels are
sort of connected in pretty
straightforward physical ways right
atoms are made of particles molecules
made of atoms all the way up to chairs
made of whatever
whereas the claim is that consciousness
is not like that and the reason why it's
not like that is because it has this
ineffable first person experience what
it is like to be something kind of thing
there is nothing that is like to be a
cherish that's a different kind of
problem so the argument is supposed to
be that you can have all the emergence
you want you will never reach
consciousness because it's a different
place to be than just being a chair now
again i don't believe that argument but
i don't think it's necessarily uh
anthropocentric or or special or
anything like that it's just i just
don't i think it's a failure of
imagination more than it is a uh being
too
hypocritical or anything like that
jimmy summer says does intuition tell
you the universe began with the big bang
or some eternal cyclic model it seems in
the former the universe has to come from
nothing and the latter the universe
doesn't have to come at all but only
because it was always here
should one seem more likely than the
other do our intuitions even mean
anything when it comes to these kinds of
questions
i don't think our intuitions should mean
very much honestly uh when we were
talking about
the beginning of the universe what does
my intuition know about anything at all
uh having said that there's two little
footnotes to that statement about
intuition one is that of course our
intuitions can get trained right we get
an intuition just from biology and from
our experience of the world but as we
learn more about theories of the
universe that are beyond our everyday
experience our intuition can grow to
encompass uh the way that those theories
work
the other thing is that we need as we
talked about before in the discussion of
bayesianism
you need some kind of prior on something
right so
if you don't know very much about the
theory of everything or quantum gravity
but you do know that either the universe
had a beginning or it didn't
bayesian reasoning says you got to put a
prior on the universe had a beginning or
the universe didn't i think that the
right thing to do in those cases where
there's no
empirical difference to us today and
there's very very little theoretical
guidance is to be pretty open-minded so
take whatever priors you want but i
think it makes sense to have priors that
are not too wildly different between the
universe lasted forever and the universe
had a beginning both are very much on
the table
dan o'neil says as a physicalist how do
you explain suicide having lost a close
family members member to suicide i find
it hard not to think of it in dualistic
non-deterministic terms as an
incorporeal mind incorporeal mind
choosing to destroy its own body
um i'm sorry to hear about your your
family member that's always a terrible
tragedy when that happens um i should i
shouldn't say that i should say it is
often a terrible tragedy when it happens
i am someone who believes that people
should be allowed to end their own lives
under precisely the right circumstances
when they're of some sound mind they
discuss things with their doctors and so
forth so there's different ways in which
that kind of thing can uh play out but
there's absolutely no question a lot of
circumstances under which people are in
depression or something like that
whether it's external circumstances or
uh you know their their neurological
signals failing them that causes them to
commit suicide when
maybe a day later they wouldn't have and
that's a completely different situation
i've also known people to whom that has
happened um
i don't i don't really think that
there's any issue here about physicalism
versus dualism to be honest if you're a
dualist like you say you can imagine the
mind choosing to destroy the body if
you're a physicalist the body is
deciding to destroy itself so the
question is are you the kind of
physicalist who thinks you can
come up with an explanation of free will
and making decisions and things like
that so i am that kind of physicalist so
when when people do things to themselves
whether it's suicide or something much
less dramatic i don't necessarily need
to interpret it in terms of any
dualistic terms
uh related question casey mahone what
are your thoughts on euthanasia so i
just gave them uh i think that it should
be allowed but i think it should be
controlled you really want to make sure
that people are doing this in you know
the clear light of day as it were not
because of some
temporary chemical imbalance or
temporary condition that they're in or
whatever uh but if if you're you're
facing terrible diseases that are not
going to go away i think that there's
absolutely a place for that in a
well-formulated society anonymous says
we have a lot of information from
history and a lot of smart people on the
planet why is it that we can't get these
smart folks to figure out a solution to
what's going on in the ukraine smart
folks found a decent vaccine for covid19
why can't we just put an end to war well
the glib answer is finding vaccines is
way easier than finding ends to war
human level questions are always going
to be much more complicated but also i
think the question is a little bit
misplaced in the sense that
there are people who wanted the war
right there are people who started the
war it's not like everyone agrees we
should find a solution to it um the
reason why we have wars is because
people have
incompatible
desires right some countries want to
control other countries or just want
think that they've been insulted or
whatever it is whatever the economic
social political religious motivations
are they're incompatible with each other
so it's nothing different than people
well it's a little bit different but
it's related to the fact that people get
in fights people get in arguments
um
you know
people do this all the time it's part of
the human condition and so i don't even
know if there is such a thing as an end
to war as long as we are human beings
what we can try to do is minimize war
and make it not be that bad right i do
think that when countries get to be
prosperous and democratic
trading with each other they are less
likely to go to war there's no absolutes
here there's no you know hard bright
lines between when countries will and
will not go to war but look the united
states and canada are not going to
invade each other anytime soon they
might annoy each other but they're not
going to send troops to control each
other and france and germany are not
going to do that i mean france and
germany is a much bigger much better
example here i mean nobody thinks
that france and germany have any
non-trivial probability of invading each
other anytime soon
but they've invaded each other a lot
over the last few centuries this is real
progress that those two countries are
not going to do that so progress is
possible okay i mean we're very very far
away from some utopian situation like
that but we can work to construct an
international order where
invading other countries just isn't done
that often it won't be a hundred percent
but uh we can work to it has nothing to
do with being smart it's not like
there's a puzzle that we're solving like
finding a virus or something like that
has much more to do
with you know motivation values like i
said uh and those are trickier things to
deal with
russell wolff
says last month you answered a question
from pablo's papa giorgio about having
multiple conceptually different models
of physics
and
mentioned the possibility that the
ultimate theory might include multiple
models that each have different domains
of applicability as you were describing
that i started to wonder if quantum
mechanics and relativity are an example
of this scenario because they use very
different language but agree in the
classical limit but then you finish by
saying we're nowhere near this becoming
a realistic question to worry about so
what's the difference between the
hypothetical you were describing and the
situation in physics today
well you know there is an overlap
between the regimes described by gravity
and the regimes described by quantum
mechanics so you said relativity
relativity in quantum mechanics are 100
compatible i think you mean gravity
which is classically described by
general relativity but uh we don't have
a good full theory of uh quantum gravity
yet as we said we have a semi-classical
theory but we don't have the full theory
yet
but it's not hard to
look at regimes where quantum mechanics
is important and gravity is important my
favorite regime is the sun
the sun causes gravity it also causes
heat and light both of these are very
important to our lives here on earth
that heat and light are generated
through quantum mechanical processes you
cannot consistently describe what the
sun does
by not including both quantum mechanics
and gravity now you sort of use
different languages when you do that but
it's the same physical situation so i
was imagining a situation where
different physical situations are
described by different models and those
sets of physical situations don't
overlap but for gravity and quantum
mechanics they definitely do overlap
liam mccarty says
my understanding is that an
interpretation of a theory is so called
because it doesn't imply any difference
in experimental results compared to
other interpretations
if so i'm curious how you pick one over
the others is it based on occam's razor
or do you interpret such an argument to
advocate for the many worlds of quantum
mechanics so
we so i guess the short answer here is
you're probably
implicitly going on the idea that we are
deciding between different
interpretations of quantum mechanics but
we're not that is just not the modern
discussion that we have in the
foundations of quantum mechanics i will
often talk about the many world's
interpretation because that is the label
that was given to it back in the day but
it's a theory it's not interpretation of
anything it's a physical theory it has a
set of uh things in this case the wave
function of the universe it has a set of
rules for what happens to those things
in this case it obeys the schrodinger
equation okay it's an ordinary physical
theory um the copenhagen interpretation
is in some sense an attempt to interpret
something but it's unclear what it's
interpreting or how it's doing it but
you know many worlds compared to like
super determinism theories or pilot wave
theories or whatever these are just
separate distinct physical theories the
word interpretation there is just uh
old-fashioned it doesn't really apply
anymore
if you did have a situation where you
had a single agreed upon physical
theory but there are different ways of
interpreting it then it's just up to you
go nuts right if you think that
newtonian mechanics is equivalent to
lagrangian mechanics or hamiltonian
mechanics the same exact physical
happenings described using different
words i don't think there's any right or
wrong there at all you just use whatever
is most convenient for the situation
you're in
kevin o'toole says whenever i hear the
word decoherence in quantum physics i
can't help but think it's named
backwards if an electron starts in a
state totally uncorrelated with anything
else then evolves into a state where
it's highly correlated with many other
particles the latter seems distinctly
more coherent a measured particle seems
more coherent than an unmeasured
particle in what sense is it intuitive
to think of decoherence as a process of
becoming less coherent uh yes that's
perfectly fair i get exactly where
you're coming from the reason for the
lingo is that the
issue of decoherence first drew notice
in the context of
you start with two particles that are
entangled
and then you measure one of them or one
of those two particles becomes
coherent it becomes entangled with the
rest of the world so imagine you're
trying to build a quantum computer okay
so you have qubits and you want them to
remain entangled
and do their thing so you put them
through gates and they evolve according
to the gates and the schrodinger
equation while remaining entangled in
the appropriate way
it would be a shame
if some photons came along and bumped
into one of your qubits
and then that qubit became entangled
with those photons but it becomes
unentangled with the other qubits in
your quantum computer that's why it's
called decoherence because within the
set of entangled things measuring one of
them or entangling one of them with the
environment deco hears it or
disentangles them with everything else
it's not the best word i i agree on that
but you know sometimes we're stuck with
the words that history gives us
p walder says within discussions around
the concept of pansysm the nature of
matter is frequently queried in
particular philip goff suggests that
physics on a fundamental level only
describes what matter does and not what
matter is can you give an explanation of
what matter is
i'll be honest i don't think this
distinction makes any sense between what
matter does and what matter is what
matter is is matter you know the stuff
of the universe i don't even like to use
the word matter because it has some
pre-existing baggage that it comes along
with i think there's the physical
universe okay and we're looking for ways
to best describe it i've argued that our
best current description is as a vector
in hilbert's base but other people will
disagree that's fine but it is whatever
it is
um i'm not even sure it would make sense
to ask what matter is or what the
universe is it's the universe it's suey
generous it is by definition a unique
thing okay even if it's many worlds then
what we mean by the universe in this
sense is all the worlds together there's
nothing like it
how in the world would you explain what
matter is in terms of something else
right i just don't know what that even
means um i do know what matter does or
you know i know certain things that it
does uh we that's all physics all of
science is what matter does that makes
perfect sense to me i think that the
desire to explain that matter is
something is just a leftover from a
pre-scientific way of thinking about
things
mishi stern says i recently heard your
interview with daniel dennett you
discussed the manifest and scientific
image my question is as the years go by
do the things in the realm of the
scientific image move to the realm of
the manifest image what once was was
considered essential becomes a useful
superficial description from molecules
to atoms to neutron protons electrons to
quarks to electrons etc
so
i think yes and no this is going to be
one of those yes and no answer questions
here um the manifest image is never
quarks and leptons that might be the
best image we have but the manifest
image is supposed to be manifest that is
to say it's supposed to be right in
front of our eyeballs at all times okay
the manifest image is supposed to be the
world that we instantly see when we look
around tables and chairs and computers
and microphones and things like that
your scientific
image gets better and better
you realize that the things are made of
atoms and quantum fields and so forth
that doesn't change the manifest image
at all and in fact i honestly think that
the whole idea of the manifest image is
under-appreciated um i think that
sometimes we skip over it when we think
about interpreting things
philosophically or scientifically you
know we go from
um
we try to say that this is the world at
the fundamental level and we kind of
imagine that we apprehend that world
directly but we don't
everything that we
see is moderated through the scientific
image even sorry the manifest image
rather even if you look at a picture
of your crystal crystallographic picture
of some atoms in a solid you're looking
at a picture you're looking at a
photograph you're not looking directly
at the atoms even if you're staring
through a microscope you're staring at
some dots on a screen right so i think
the manifest image actually like plays
an important role in how we interpret
the world we're constantly comparing
the
parts and features of our best
scientific practice to the manifest
image so i don't think it really changes
over time it might change a little bit
you know if you learn this and then it's
easy to like flip a switch and go oh the
earth goes around the sun not the other
way around that's fine but the fact that
there's something called the earth and
something called the sun those are both
part of the manifest image and they're
not going anywhere
napoleon's corporal says i recently read
somewhere that bell's theorem has been
called the most profound discovery of
science one of your strengths is
explaining challenging concepts so that
they are understandable to
non-scientists would you explain the
details of the test experiment that
supposedly proves the violation of
locality your opinion of the test and
the result and how that fits into the
many worlds concept
i don't think it's
actually very complicated um bell's
inequality just says
imagine that you have two sets of
observations that are separated okay so
they're space-like separated they cannot
signal back and forth to each other and
in the back of your mind you have
something like two entangled particles
right and you're going to measure them
in some axis up or down but not always
along the same axis you're going to
measure them at different angles and
what bell noticed is that in quantum
mechanics because of entanglement
these things could be really
highly correlated okay
now classically they could be correlated
also but given things like the
uncertainty principle and so forth
there's an upper limit on how
correlated they could be
if there was no wave function that
spread across the distance right if
there were only objects with definite
values at different locations of space
there's an upper limit to the amount of
correlation because you're not predict
you're not specifying ahead of time what
observation you're going to make right
you can always just say well i i pick um
you know particle that is spin up and i
know the other one is spin down okay but
if it's just classical
um then you need to tell me what happens
if i measure it along a different axis
in quantum mechanics where there's a
superposition you have a very definite
answer to that but you have to invent
some theory for what is going to be the
measurement outcomes if you measure
along a different axis
and what bell proved is that that
theorem could never be as correlated as
it would be in
quantum mechanics because of the fact
that in quantum mechanics the wave
function spreads across these two
particles even though they're very very
far away so that is interpreted as
evidence for locality but look
as i said before
i think many worlds is right
so to me this is not a profound result
at all it's a very simple
consequence of the fact that the wave
function describes the world right
bell's theorem seems very profound if
you were going to doubt that the wave
function describes the world wave
functions are not local that's just how
they are they describe what is going on
all over the place at the same time okay
it's it's profoundly non-local so if you
already thought that quantum mechanics
was many worlds bell's theorem is you
know you're giving bells to go yeah sure
that's that's not extra profound is
already part of the profoundness because
i already believe that the wave function
is the whole thing there you go
perry romanowski says i often tell
people that if you rewound time all the
things that happened would still happen
the same way recently a friend pushed
back and said he wasn't it wasn't
correct because of heisenberg's
uncertainty principle i think that's a
misunderstanding of the uncertainty
principle which of us is correct um it's
not the uncertainty principle
for sure that's not what is going on as
we already discussed the uncertainty
principle before but
it's actually a difficult question to
answer because as many as often happens
with these questions it depends on your
favorite formulation of quantum
mechanics
so
um if you are copenhagen quantum
mechanics person
then no what would happen if you
re-round the world would not be exactly
the same because there is a truly random
element in the laws of physics okay when
you observe something it truly collapses
in an unpredictable way likewise in
objective collapse models that have
nothing to do with observers right like
there are grw models and penrose's
models and so forth where the wave
function really does collapse randomly
and if you thought that was the
be all and end all the laws of physics
then if you rewound the tape it would
not play the same thing
now in uh something like a pilot wave
theory in bohmian mechanics that is
deterministic
okay but the determinism is governed by
some hidden variables that you don't
have access to so if you rewound the
tape starting with the same values of
the hidden variables then indeed you
would get exactly the same history
played back and then as usual many
worlds is in this middle position where
the wave function of the universe
uh evolves in exactly the same way
but there's many many universes right
there's many many copies of the universe
and it's not clear what you mean
when you say
my universe would be the same there's
lots of universes and they'd be
different from each other one of them
would be the same as yours the other
ones would be different okay
nowhere in any of those words that i
mentioned the heisenberg uncertainty
principle because it's this all has to
do with measurement which as i said
before isn't about the uncertainty
principle
tim ryan says how is the bass playing
going have you explored any music theory
it can be very fun and rewarding
yeah you know the bass playing was going
really well uh before i went to boston
for my sabbatical in the fall and i
didn't bring the bass because i was
trying to focus on other things and
since i've gotten back i've just been
swamped with other stuff it's really i
have too many things on my plate right
now part of the reason why this ama is a
little delayed um so i've fallen off on
the bass playing i was playing it every
day at least a little bit and it's not
like that anymore it is fun and
rewarding i like doing it uh i wish i
had more time to do it i have every
intention in the world of finding more
time to do it at some point in the
future i'm not quite sure what that
point will be tom says i really enjoyed
the arvin agreement episode on the
gene's eye view of evolution
in your experience does the i would die
for two brothers or eight cousins rubric
have explanatory power for how people
treat others in the world
eg is the lower degree of genetic
overlap a primary explanation for the
west historically devoting fewer
resources to sub-saharan african africa
than to other eurasian populations
you know i think that uh it's worth
saying
about that idea that you would die for
two brothers or eight cousins that
uh
the
our unconscious is not that good at math
so even if there's something to that
motto
it's certainly not true that we really
follow that at a careful
quantitative level
rather how i would interpret that is
saying that evolution kind of trains us
to favor our family
and maybe even
uh well as as is often true with
evolution
evolution doesn't actually
change our traits right the thing the
the the thing that about the selfish
gene theory the gene's eye view
that certainly is correct
is that what is passed on from
generation to generation is our genome
right
the
pressure the selection pressure acts on
traits that we have as organisms but
then the result of that is that certain
genes get passed on the next generations
and other ones don't
so
the genes that get passed on is going
are going to you know give us certain
traits and those traits might be
be a little bit more concerned with your
relatives right but i don't know how
genes would even be able to tune
themselves to such a degree where they
would say
care as much for your own life as for
two brothers brothers or eight cousins
or anything like that it's much more
vague than that so i absolutely think
that that kind of
selection helps explain why
we are more likely to do things for
people more like us right closer to us
um i think as uh nicholas christakis
said back in his podcast episode we have
a weak in-group bias
so all else being equal we are going to
draw a circle around people like us and
people not like us and prefer the people
like us and that's true in many many
ways and that makes perfect evolutionary
sense but i wouldn't get too precisely
quantitative about it
paul torek says gary mark has said that
for an ai to have common sense it needs
certain mental faculties we have
including to quote him a cost-benefit
system which i think is innate you seem
to agree or at least not object yet in
your may ama you question the idea
that an ai will have values you're
replying to a question about stuart
russell's argument that ai presents an
alignment problem because ai's values
might not align with hours have you
changed your mind about whether or not
artificial general intelligence will
probably have values
so the point i was trying to make is
that i mean an ai will act in certain
ways okay
and that way that the ai acts can
certainly
be
accounted for in terms of a cost benefit
system the point i was trying to make
was that that kind of cost benefit
system that the ai might end up having
need not be recognizable to us as a set
of values
okay if i throw a rock outside the
window it falls down but i don't say it
values being down it values being at a
lower elevation i say it's just
following the rules of gravity okay so
i'm open to the possibility that ai's
will act in such a way that we could
sensibly take the human centered concept
of values and apply them to ais there's
no obstacle in principle to that i just
want to be open-minded about it i'm also
open to the possibility that ai's will
not be recognizable as things with
values they will be recognizable as
things that do things and that those
things can be accounted for by
cost-benefit analysis but it may or may
not make sense to talk about them as
having values
razi ahmed says why is schrodinger's
equation constructed such that it only
has a time derivative if time and space
are essentially the same why single out
one coordinate
well schrodinger's equation is part of
quantum mechanics
time and space being the same is a
lesson that we get from relativity and
in uh quantum mechanics as as it was
originally formulated in
non-relativistic quantum mechanics they
were different time and space
schrodinger's equation is a formulation
of quantum dynamics that does treat time
and space differently so
uh you can ask is that incompatible with
the lessons of relativity and the answer
is yeah to work do some work in there
and this again special relativity okay
not general relative you're not talking
about gravity you're just talking about
the speed of light being the speed limit
and so forth um it's 100 compatible
but it's sort of
spiritually intention if that makes
sense what i mean is that whenever you
write down
a quantum mechanical state as a wave
function in some frame of reference in a
relativistic theory so you have you know
the standard model of particle physics
that is a completely relativistic theory
i can pick
a reference frame i can say here are my
coordinates on space time here's my
reference frame and with respect to that
reference frame i can construct a
quantum state and it will evolve
according to the schrodinger equation
okay
so what i've done is i have broken the
manifest sorry i've
taken the lorenzen variance the uh
invariance with respect to different
coordinate systems and i have made it
non-manifest by choosing a coordinate
system this is what we do all the time
you know we choose coordinate systems
all the time but we know that that's
just a choice that we made then we
describe what's happening in that
coordinate system but the underlying
dynamics if your dynamics are
relativistic they don't care you could
use a different coordinate system and
get the same physics
same thing is true in quantum mechanics
you could choose different coordinate
systems you would describe the quantum
state differently
but it would still have a schrodinger
equation that evolved it forward in time
so that symmetry between space and time
can be hidden
by a choice that we arbitrarily make but
no physical results depend on that
arbitr arbitrary choice that we made
nicholas walker says when is the book
out based on biggest ideas and will it
be e-reader-friendly
uh is scheduled to come out in september
of this year 2022
um it's supposed to be reader friendly
there's definitely going to be
electronic additions we are working hard
to make sure the equations come out
right i you know i am not there in the
design department of whatever the
electronic
bookseller is or anything like that so
you know i'm not the one to complain to
if they don't but we're trying we
certainly want it all to be um
operational it's a challenge that my
publisher who publishes trade books is
not
used to but they recognize the challenge
and they're working hard at making it
all
work
claudio says
i thought i had an understanding of the
cause of hawking radiation from black
holes however lately i heard some
conflicting versions that made me
realize that my version pairs of
particles popping out into space one of
them falls into the black hole the other
flies the other direction is pure bs
can you give us an updated no click bait
explanation for the origin of hawking
radiation
so i wouldn't say that that's pure bs in
fact that explanation you just gave
pairs of particles popping out into
space
has also been given by stephen hawking
in his popular writings right so he
knows what the real explanation is but
it always depends on what you mean by
real or correct because there's
different levels here okay
you know here's
a set of statements that are true and
they may or may not satisfy you
if you have a black hole
and there are quantum fields you're in a
world that has quantum field theory and
there's a black hole configuration then
if you imagine converting exchanging
that black hole
for a slightly smaller black hole plus
some outgoing
radiation that configuration slightly
smaller black hole plus outgoing
radiation
has all of the same conserved quantities
same energy same angular momentum same
charge and whatever and a higher entropy
okay
the conserved quantities are important
because you'll never get evolution from
like a state with one uh electric charge
to a different electric charge or
something like that but within the
configurations that have the same
conserved quantities you expect
physical
objects or whatever you want to call
them to evolve into states of higher
entropy and that's exactly what the
black hole is doing okay there you go
that's a reason to expect that black
hole should evaporate should give off
radiation it's not quite the physical
mechanism beneath it if you want to
understand that physical mechanism
beneath it and you don't
and you correctly think that the story
about pairs of particles fluctuating out
of existence is a little bit too
hand-wavy and click-baity
you have to admit that there is such a
thing as quantum fields okay and quantum
fields evolve with time and this
statement of
particles and antiparticle pairs popping
in out of existence is a colorful
metaphorical way of expressing the fact
that quantum fields live in
superpositions of zero particles one
particle two particles etc and the
particular superposition of the quantum
fields in the vicinity of the black hole
event horizon is unstable it tends to
leak out particles the existence of
particles outside the black hole grows
with time and the size of the black hole
shrinks with time under evolution
according to the schrodinger equation
if you want to know more details than
that then you need the math then you
know read hawking's paper or read a good
textbook on it i mean you really got to
dig into it but it is exactly what is
predicted by the theory of quantum field
theory in curved spacetime there you go
matt hickman says what do you think the
odds are there's an extinction level
event for humanity in the next 100 years
do you think we're doing more or less
enough to prevent such a thing or should
we be doing more
well i think there's different
kinds of extinction events i think
extinction level event is hard to
imagine honestly it's not zero certainly
um but even a major thermonuclear war
wouldn't
be wouldn't render humanity extinct it
might wipe out uh advanced technological
civilization if it were bad enough but
it wouldn't render us extinct uh i mean
maybe it would be so catastrophic that
100 000 years in the future we would all
have died out so maybe you would count
that as an extinction level event
but mostly i think that you know i i'm
more worried about really bad events
that are not quite extinction level uh
like if only a million people died i
think that would be bad if 100 million
or a billion people died that's all the
worse right so i think we should worry
more about those events than probably we
do
and it's easy to understand why human
beings are just not meant not built to
appreciate risks that occur on time
scales longer than a human lifetime
right
so there's a one percent chance of a
billion people dying because of some
event
per century
things that happen once per century are
just not things that human beings are
good at preventing we're not even good
at preventing things that might happen
next year right
so i do think we could be better at uh
worrying about
nuclear war biological warfare uh
accidental or terroristic use of nuclear
weapons and biological weapons big solar
flares
terrible pandemics things like that
asteroids hitting the earth asteroids
actually pretty small
uh number but again it's pretty cheap to
worry about it compared to the other
ones so i do think we should be doing
more but it's not like a huge amount
more it's not i don't think we need to
spend large fractions of our gdps uh
worrying about those things we need to
spend a small but prudent fraction on
them
eric chen says what is the largest
cardinality of infinity used in modern
physics do infinite sets with
cardinality greater than that of the
real numbers have any use in physics
so you may have heard for those of you
who are not experts that
there's different levels of infinity
the number of integers is infinite but
it is less than the number of real
numbers which is a bigger infinity and
which infinity we're talking about is
the cardinality of the set
um and there are bigger infinities than
the number of real numbers
so roughly speaking eric physicists
don't care about the stuff at all
that to a first approximation the
difference between different kinds of
infinity is just irrelevant to physics
now there are certain corners of physics
where they're a little bit more
mathematically careful where countable
versus uncountable
namely integer level infinities versus
real number level infinities do matter
to them in certain corners of
mathematical physics especially quantum
field theory and quantum mechanics
so they care about those things but
there's no
experimental difference right i mean
there's no uh
uh empirical result that depends
on whether or not the reality of the
situation is countable or uncomfortable
as far as i know
beyond uncountable beyond just the
number of real numbers the cardinality
of real numbers i know of no use in
physics uh but maybe i wouldn't like
maybe there is some in some deep deep
corner of mathematical physics that i'm
not aware about but anyway not does not
percolate into most working physicist
consciousness
pete faulkner says listening to your
wondrum course on time and i heard you
talk about cp lear which is an
experimental particle physics experiment
uh and the demonstration of time
asymmetry in the weak force could this
time asymmetry be in some way an
explanation of the matter antimatter
asymmetry we see in the universe well it
could be related um but it's probably
not the explanation for two reasons
number one what we see in the
experiments uh like cp leer which looks
at uh chaos and anti-kaons
that's a time reversal and variance
violation from the standard model of
particle physics and that violation just
numerically
seems to be too small to play an
important role in explaining the matter
anti-matter asymmetry in the universe
the other point is that to explain the
matter anti-minority symmetry as sakurai
pointed out a long time ago you need
more than just
time asymmetry you need time asymmetry
char baryon asymmetry kind of obviously
and you need to departure from thermal
equilibrium you need them all in the
right place at the right time working
together in the right way so
it's impossible just to point to one of
those you know violation of time
asymmetry and say that's why there is
this difference between matter and
antimatter you need all three at once
baryon asymmetry time asymmetry uh
thermo thermal equilibrium violation
maybe you have that in the early
universe probably you do since there's
more matter than anti-matter in the
universe but we don't know which of the
many many specific scenarios for that
asymmetry is the right one right now
oleg ruvinsky says you mentioned in the
past that you love ian banks's culture
series what are your favorites in it and
why
uh i think my favorite is accession
actually um i can never look i'll be
honest i don't think that his titles are
great so i can never remember which plot
goes with which title of the books
except for like easy ones like player
games but accession is the one that
places the most emphasis on the minds
these giant ai spaceships they're
talking to each other telling jokes and
everything i just like that that's why
that's why it's my favorite book that's
a kind of a cheap answer but there you
go
rob griber says you recently had two
podcast guests who talked about language
specifically the mathematics and
analytics underneath human vocabulary
language and stories number 174 with
today bradley and number 181 with peter
dodds
listening to both episodes it seems
bradley laid out a theoretical
explanation of language and dodds does a
sort of experimentalist application of
some kind of approach like that i'd be
curious to hear your thoughts on this
field of study generally is this
analytical study of language and stories
just a descriptive exercise about
emerging language of our culture or does
it have some power to help us understand
what deeper general ai for example might
look like um
i'm not quite sure if i understand the
two options uh here they seem both
completely compatible to me it can be a
descriptive exercise about an emergent
aspect of our culture and have the power
to help us understand what deeper
general ai might look like you know
emergent aspects of culture or anything
else aren't arbitrary right there are
reasons why certain things emerge and
certain things don't so the fact that we
use language in certain ways that the
entropy that we can assign to different
words or phrases or sentences
uh has certain structure certain
patterns this is not arbitrary there are
reasons why it is like that so
it uh both is a descriptive exercise
trying to understand how we actually
talk uh the information that is conveyed
how we use language to sway people make
persuasive arguments toy with people's
emotions
and also give us some insight into how
ai might itself use language like i said
before
it would be a little bit presumptuous to
imagine that ai is just like us
i especially think that um
i forget whether i've talked about this
on the podcast or not but
uh the fact that
artificial intelligences are generally
these days not embodied right they don't
have bodies they're just in software and
they certainly don't have the kind of
complicated biological bodies that you
and i have i think this matters a lot i
think our bodies are crucially important
to making us who we are as human beings
we are not just software that is working
on any different machine that you want
to run it on uh but okay aside from that
i do think that there's probably
regularities and similarities in how
general intelligences will speak to each
other but i'm open i'm willing to do the
experiment there too so it's it's you
know if we find ways that human beings
use language that can be mathematically
studied
it's a hypothesis to say that agi will
also have those features and then we can
go test that hypothesis when we actually
get it
phil says is there a deeper reason why
quantization works so well
why would replacing classical
observables with operators give such
good results or maybe i should ask this
the other way around since quantum
mechanics is more fundamental
yeah you know in some sense you should
ask it the other way around the question
is
we have quantum mechanics why is there a
good classical limit okay and that's a
non-trivial question uh again one of the
recent papers that ashmeat singh and i
wrote together
is pointing in the direction of
answering that question other people
long before us have thought about it why
and under what circumstances is there a
classical limit to quantum mechanics but
there is but your question is actually a
little bit deeper than that because even
if there were a classical limit
even if you have theory a
and under the right circumstances
there's a limit of that theory that
looks like a different theory theory b
okay
the question we're asking here is how
could you ever reconstruct theory a just
given theory b reconstruct the full
theory from the limit
in principle there's no reason at all
why you should be able to do that i mean
the limit might only give you a tiny
hint of what's going on in more general
circumstances
so
that's why i think you shouldn't expect
that every single quantum theory in fact
it's certainly not true that every
single quantum theory comes about by
quantizing a classical theory the weird
thing is that in our experience
we've done pretty well
in
finding out what the quantum theories of
nature are by starting with the
classical theory and quantizing it
that's the weird thing why are the
theories that work for us
in that particular class of theories
where you can reverse engineer the full
theory from the classical limit that i
have less strong ideas about i'm really
not sure why that is true
maybe there is a good theory for that
and and of course i also think it's
failing in the case of gravity so that's
that would have to be a uh thing to
consider when you're inventing the
explanation to this puzzle
valero says a bit of a dark question but
would you rather survive a nuclear
exchange or be amongst the first to go i
think it's pretty easy to say i'd rather
survive right i mean
yeah you know throughout most of human
history times were tough times are still
tough for many people right now
the fact that you live in circumstances
where times are tough does not take away
my motivation to live and try to make
things better in fact you know
it's easier to know what to do to make
things better when times are really
really tough because you just have to
like make people survive and help out
each other and i would want to be around
for that
robert ruxin rescue says in my system of
values my moral system i think
everything is acceptable as long as no
suffering is brought by that action
suffering is what gives an act its moral
worthiness however using this framework
brings me to a very taboo situations for
most people like the situation where a
pedophile is satisfying his or her
sexual fantasies doing a video chat with
a parent who bathes their baby let's say
the parent gets the money pedophile gets
sexual satisfaction without hurting
anybody and the baby is just completely
unaware of anything like this happening
in my own system of values this whole
situation is not immoral i've been
trying to analyze it to see if i'm
making a mistake anywhere but i don't
see anything wrong with it however most
people would be appalled at my
conclusion and think i'm insane do you
see anything wrong here is there any
argument i could use to come up with the
conclusion this situation is wrong
so i think that the situation here
there's two things going on one is that
sure many people's
morality comes very much from instinct
rather than from a um
well worked out rational system and
that's not even necessarily a bad thing
you know it's not ideal i would prefer
if everyone uh were completely rational
but i don't think that as i've often
said that morality is
a simple matter of just being rational
you need some starting point and your
intuitions your your inner feelings are
the starting point i think the morality
comes about
by starting with some moral inclinations
or intuitions that we have and trying to
make them into a rational system i think
there's a mistake to be made by
inventing a rational system and then
saying that even though this disagrees
with my intuitions i nevertheless i'm
gonna stick with the system because the
whole point of the system was to
systematize your intuitions okay but
that's that's one aspect the the bigger
aspect that you're asking about is are
there arguments that you're not
considering that might make this
situation immoral or moral rather you
know i i can imagine there would be
situations
like this in some very very broad sense
which i think could be perfectly moral
the particular one that you're writing
about i think it's pretty easy for me to
see where it's where it could be argued
to be not moral
i mean i think the the basic lesson is
that it's a little bit too simple
to do philosophical thought experiments
of this form and neglect features of the
real world
and features of the real world matter in
these circumstances um in particular
both the parent and the pedophile in
this circumstance you have to be
sure are not going to do anything that
actually does call cause harm to people
right i mean it's a little bit weird for
a parent to be pimping out their baby to
um give cheap thrills to a pedophile and
and imagine that the parent doesn't do
anything else that we might find
objectionable i think that's going to be
the origin of a lot of people's worries
there
but more importantly and this is really
the heart of the matter to me
i don't think it's fair to say the baby
is just completely unaware of anything
like this happening you know i think
that it is okay
to be troubled by things you would think
are bad even if everyone is unaware of
them right and in particular in the case
of this baby maybe they will grow up and
find out about it and be very very
disturbed sometime in the future you can
certainly not know for sure that that
won't happen right
so it's just much easier safer
a better moral choice to not put the
baby in that kind of situation where the
baby has no agency to give consent for
anything like that so to me that kind of
argument is a perfectly good reason not
to allow something like the situation
you're talking about
steve pilling says what do you think of
the black hole as fuzz ball or ball of
string model it seems to avoid
problematic issues with the singularity
where serger sir professor roger penrose
says that space and time come to an end
um you know i don't know a lot about it
i've tried to understand it for those of
you who don't know there is a model that
is uh most associated with samir mather
of ohio state university where he tries
to
let's put it this way
if you think that information gets out
of black holes eventually if you think
that the laws of quantum mechanics are
purely information conserving including
processes such as black hole evaporation
and you think that string theory is the
right theory of the world then you need
to believe that black holes can be
described in the context of string
theory in a way that is perfectly
happy to just obey the schrodinger
equation for evolution right there have
to be a set of degrees of freedom in
hilbert's space that interact with the
outside world et cetera et cetera and
the question becomes
what are those degrees of freedom how do
we think about them and so uh mather has
described a way or proposed a kind of
way to think of the black hole
as a
fuzzball as a c as a set of strings that
are sort of tied up together and wound
up in different ways my impression and
i've tried to understand this and not
quite succeeded because i think that in
part because no one understands it in
part because of my limitations
but um
it's not a complete description so samir
is able to describe what would happen in
certain very very very special
circumstances you know perfectly
extremal black holes and supersymmetrics
supersymmetric situations etc but not
give a completely generic understanding
of an ordinary black hole that you might
find in our galaxy or something like
that so it's hard to know what to think
of the proposal because i don't think
it's fully fleshed out yet i mean maybe
it has been since i last paid attention
to it but that's my impression
um i do think that
the general idea has to be on the right
track again if you think that
information is conserved coming out of
black holes which i think is likely but
i'm 100 wedded to it um there have to be
some degrees of freedom in there you
know it's almost like
i i don't see how you can object to it
right i mean people sometimes read about
this and they're acting as if they're
translating it as if there's not really
a black hole because instead there's a
bunch of strings behind the event
horizon that's just not the way i would
think about it at all it's saying that
what is behind the black hole
is a bunch of strings you know it's it's
it might be perceived to an in-falling
observer just as ordinary space-time
inside a black hole but you know in
string theory the world is made of
strings so there's a specific
configuration of those strings that
makes up a black hole that is different
than the configuration you find that
makes up empty space or the earth or
something like that so something like
that even if we don't know the details
yet is going to have to be true if
string theory is on the right track
ezra parzibak says what are your
thoughts on preppers or prepping for
disaster personally
uh you know nuanced thoughts i hope you
know i'm in favor of being prepared for
disasters look i live in los angeles
there are real disasters that happen
around here whether they're um
brush fires or earthquakes or mudslides
or droughts or whatever so we are you
know not very well prepared for that
kind of thing but we have our little
earthquake kit okay you know we have
some water and some food and
first aid stuff uh flashlights and
things like that
that makes perfect sense i mean why
would anyone object to preparing for
potential bad things happening to you
now of course the answer to that why
would anyone object is that some people
take it too far they fetishize the idea
of preparing for disasters that are
extremely unlikely there's a bigger
discussion to be had here about
the whole way we think about
really bad possibilities that happen
really rarely right a low probability
event but it would be really really
disastrous this goes back to questions
we've already talked about in the ama
i think that
those kinds of questions are
intrinsically difficult i don't think we
have a
well formulated clear theory of how to
deal with them and the reason why is
because
it's not just a matter let me put it
this way when you have things that are
of fairly ordinary probabilities between
1 and 99 let's say
and the consequences would be
pretty bad or pretty good but not
overwhelmingly good not like end of the
world or ascend to heaven kind of stuff
but somewhere in between
and then roughly speaking you can
multiply the probability by the utility
plus or minus of that event happening
and work on the basis of that okay and
be kind of a consequentialist about the
whole thing
when the probabilities become 10 to the
minus 6 or 10 to the minus 12 or
something like that but the consequences
become
cosmically good or bad
it's not it's no longer just a matter of
multiplying the probability by the uh
utility because maybe there's an error
bar on your probability right you don't
really know and who knows what the space
of possibilities is and i i love this uh
one of the gems of wisdom i took from
the podcast interview with martin reese
was in the context of the large hadron
collider turning on and potentially
swallowing the earth right and
physicists worked out
all the probabilities and they said it's
possible was very very very unlikely and
people said well it's destroying the
earth even if it's possible at all you
shouldn't do it
and martin reese's response was well
it's possible but unlikely that you get
free energy forever a perpetual motion
machine out of science that comes out of
the lhc it's possible
unlikely but possible and the point is
that
the space of very very unlikely events
is something that we don't have a good
handle on
uh
plus or minus so anyway this is getting
far away from the preparation question
but i wish we had a better
set of rules for being rational in these
cases of extreme uncertainty and extreme
risk combined together and that's kind
of what is going on in the prepper
community where they really yeah there
are people out there who treat prepping
for a big natural disaster as something
like that should take up uh an hour a
day of your time which is probably way
more than it deserves honestly so
there's some happy medium in there to be
found
okay holographic cosmology asks a
priority question
we used two eyes to focus on one
object's position to create the illusion
of depth we didn't always have this
ability it had to evolve is it possible
that we're looking at space wrong could
we be missing depth or other information
that we need two or more eyes capable of
looking in two different positions at
once in order to find
you know never say never i would say but
my strong feeling is no that we're not
missing
something analogous to depth in the same
way and the reason why is because we've
gone far far far beyond what our two
eyes can tell us about space we
understand a lot about space we're able
to do experiments in it the inverse
square law behavior of gravity and
electromagnetism
depends crucially on the fact that space
is macroscopically three-dimensional
there's many many pieces that go into
our current understanding of space any
one of which would go wrong if we were
missing something dramatic like a whole
new
sense of depth or something like that so
our eyes were really useful back in the
day but we're not dependent on them in
the same way to get our best scientific
image of the world these days
louis b says
following up on the previous answers
regarding falsifiability as a criterion
for science in a beyond falsifiability
worldview where does the hypothesis of a
supernatural god fit philosophically i
know you consider it a bad hypothesis
but is it a scientific one the
supernatural and gods are typically
dispensed with as non-scientific because
they are non-falsifiable but it wouldn't
seem but it would seem you don't have
this luxury is positing a god somehow
less scientific than hypothesizing what
is beyond the edge of the observable
universe or inside a black hole um so
two things one i think you should read
more carefully
or or read the paper i wrote uh on
beyond falsifiability because the point
is not that there was some idea that we
agreed on that scientific theories need
to be falsifiable and we're changing
that idea that is not the what's going
on what's going on is that there was
this idea uh from popper that involved
falsifiability as a demarcation
criterion between scientific and
non-scientific and it never was accepted
philosophers of science never had a
period of time where most of them were
on board with this idea because it turns
out that demarcating science from
non-science is more subtle than that but
at the same time they were appreciative
of what that
idea was trying to get at
and so it's not a matter of saying we
don't need falsifiability anymore it's a
matter of saying okay falsifiability is
a step in the right direction but we
need to do better and we're continuing
to do better that's the beyond that
we're talking about in this sense we
want theories that are empirically
judged and theories that are definite in
what they say about what happens in the
universe okay
and
as far as that is concerned so
the reaction in my paper is not against
popper who's just a step in our
understanding a better and better
understanding of how science works but
against scientists in the current era
who misuse popper by being lazy you know
they think that there's a motto that
they can put on a bumper sticker that
tells them what a theory is scientific
or not and that's just not the world is
just not that simple
it's a little bit more complicated than
that sorry so those scientists need to
do better at their philosophy of science
and
likewise there's a whole bunch of
atheists who are
a tip who are similarly subject to
oversimplifying things to get where they
want to go they want to go to the fact
to the result that you shouldn't take
theism seriously and so they say well
it's not like a scientific theory it's
not falsifiable therefore we shouldn't
consider it you've never heard me say
that i think that is lazy and silly to
say those things okay that's why as i
said before i had a talk said saying god
is not a good theory
it did not say god is not a theory god
is a perfectly good theory it's a
statement about the ontology of the
world saying there's more than just the
physical in the world okay and we should
judge that idea about the physical world
how in exactly the same way that we
judge any other scientific theory one
way or the other we ask what predictions
it makes what we should expect if it was
true and we compare those predictions
against the world in which we live okay
so i don't see any problem i've never
said that supernatural or gods are
non-scientific i think the whole idea of
what is called uh methodological
naturalism the idea that science starts
by assuming natural explanations for
phenomena 100 wrong that is total
totally bogus okay what science is is
methodologically empiricist
it judges things by the predictions that
those things make for the world
so i think that god makes predictions i
think that if god existed the world be a
very different place it would be very
very noticeable if god existed that's
the whole point that's why it's not a
very good theory
kathy seeger says michael dyne wrote in
his new book about weinberg's weak
anthropic principle just to explain the
cosmos constant would require an absurd
number of different universes 10 to the
power of 120 at least but far more if
other constants of nature are fixed this
way and he wrote such a mode for
explaining the world around us is just
too much to swallow would you as a
person not shy of invoking a huge number
a huge amount of worlds in quantum
mechanics be as hesitant as dyn
regarding the multiverse so i actually i
mean i read michael's book um but i
don't remember that exact line cause you
know i i know this stuff pretty well i
skim sometimes okay when reading popular
physics books um but i know that michael
dyne takes the anthropic principle
totally seriously himself
including the necessary number of
universes so he might have been you know
either describing a point of view that
he temporarily had or maybe describing
the point of view of skeptics of the
whole idea but he's absolutely willing
to consider this many universes uh
personally you know when you say
statements like um an absurd number of
different universes
i don't know how to respond to that what
what what counts as an absurd number of
different universes i i recognize the
difference between one universe and two
universes you know if you can get away
with just one universe that would be
better i mean in favor of that all else
being equal but i don't think you can
all else being equal i think you have to
make certain uh sacrifices that are that
are too far to go in order to make that
happen
but once you have two
then there's no difference in my mind
between 2 and 10 to the 120 or 10 to the
10 to the 10 to the 10 to the 10 to the
120 factorial like who cares it's a
number it's a big number don't worry
about how
it considers how it sounds to be absurd
or ridiculous to your puny little human
brain i don't think that's something we
should worry about that much
anita tomasek says
does
does state of thermodynamic equilibrium
of the universe in which does a state a
thermodynamic equilibrium of the
universe in which times arrow no longer
exists affect in any way our
four-dimensional structure of space-time
i doubt it but i wonder how it looks
like highly hypothetically from a
god-like point of view perspective of
the bloc universe so
i think the answer is no if i understand
the question correctly um if the
universe were in thermal equilibrium
four-dimensional space-time would still
be four-dimensional space-time um
except there'd be no arrow of time so i
always try to distinguish between time
as a coordinate on space time and the
arrow of time which is the feature of
the behavior of matter and stuff in the
universe which differentiates the past
from the future you know there's no
arrow of space
if you're out there in space floating
between the planets there's no
difference between up down left right
forward backward but there's space space
still exists you don't need an arrow for
something to exist the arrow time is a
feature of time
but it is not time itself so time would
still exist in thermodynamic equilibrium
in particular if you just imagine a box
of gas as a simple model right as we
like to do when we do thermodynamics
thought experiments if you had a box of
gas and thermodynamic equilibrium
the macroscopic features of the box of
the gas in the box do not change with
time you're in equilibrium but
microscopically the particles are still
moving there's still time evolution
there so time and space would still
exist in the ordinary way
herbert berkowitz says
i recently saw a reference to a particle
called the anti-neutrino
that is true in fact you've seen
references you've heard references
earlier in this podcast
that stopped me in my tracks how can a
particle with no charge possibly have an
anti-particle that will obliviate it
so there's a short answer to this and a
longer answer to this the short answer
is
it doesn't a neutrino does not have
electric charge but a neutrino does have
lepton number
and the lepton number can be positive or
negative and the lepton number is
conserved that's why in this example of
so
it took me a while to get it right there
but when a tau decays to a muon
okay so a tau has
tau number as well as lepton number a
muon has mu number as well as uh lepton
number so if a tau turns into a muon the
lepton number is the same
the um electric charge is the same but
town numbers suddenly change the muon
numbers so that can't be right because
they're both conserved at least as far
as we know therefore you need to have
tau number carried away somehow and is
carried away by a tau neutrino
but that gives you extra lepton number
so you need
to get rid of the lepton number to
cancel it off and also to cancel off the
extra muon number and you do that by
adding one anti-muon
neutrino so and this is what is actually
happening when you go into the details i
did a lot of this in my um higgs boson
book the particle at the end of the
universe if you're interested so a tau
actually decays into a muon a muon
anti-neutrino and a tau neutrino
the longer answer is the word obliviate
bothers me a little bit there because
this idea that every particle has an
anti-particle that is defined by the
thing that annihilates it is way too
simplistic
what there are is a bunch of particles
they interact and all those interactions
are in accord with the symmetries and
conserved quantities of the standard
model of particle physics
it is convenient to separate particles
into particles and antiparticles but
it is not a fundamental feature of
nature uh with the existence the the
fact that there is a fundamental the
fundamental feature that exists is that
certain kinds of particles that have
quantities like spin like a neutrino has
better have anti-particles unless
there is some fundamental breaking of
the symmetry um
well let's put it this way once you have
spin you can imagine anti-particles you
don't need to have them i'm hesitating
because there are
majorana theories of neutrinos where you
could have some kinds of neutrinos
without anti-particles but that's a
whole different complicated kind of
thing which proves my point my point is
that there's not a simple distinction
into particles and antiparticles in
nature
i mean photons right photons
do they not have an antiparticle or are
they their own antiparticle the real
answer is it's more complicated than
that the antiparticle particle
distinction is not the be-all and
end-all of this way of talking
peter bamber says i understand that in
general relativity time is not absolute
that the passage of time at different
points in space varies because of mass
energy densities between and around the
points i've also heard it said that in
quantum mechanics time is a fixed
backdrop along which wave functions
evolve are these views incompatible and
if so is this one of the reasons why gr
and qm are difficult to combine in a
single theory
so i'm going to say no to a bunch of
things here and it's not your fault
peter you've been misled by the world um
it's not true that the passage of time
at different points in space varies the
passage of time is always one second per
second it is never two seconds per
second i don't even know what that would
mean the true fact in relativity whether
special or general is that there can be
different amounts of time elapsed if you
take different paths between the same
two events
so in special relativity that happens
because one path is sort of curvy you
zoom out there in a spaceship and zoom
back and the other one is straight
whereas in general relativity they can
both be pretty straight as long as one
of them hangs out in a strong
gravitational field
sometimes this set of words is sort of
mangled into saying
that the rate of time flows differently
at different points but i think that's
just a bad way of thinking about it
having said all that as far as quantum
mechanics and and gravity are concerned
this is related to a problem but this is
not the problem you know
in general relativity
there is no obvious choice of time
parameter in the same way that there is
in special relativity or in well in
newtonian mechanics there's a perfectly
obvious choice of time parameter because
there's only one
in special relativity there's a set of
different choices you can make depending
on different inertial reference frames
but they're all on an equal footing
they're all equally good
for whatever problem you want in general
relativity there's an infinitely bigger
set of different things you can use but
again they're all fine you know
people in general relativity talk about
many-fingered time so time can sort of
you can move your slicing of the
universe in different ways in different
regions it's all fine that's not really
one of the fundamental issues in uh
quantum gravity it's closely related to
a fundamental issue which is called the
problem of time which is that if you
just naively quantize general relativity
for a closed universe with zero energy
like we were talking about uh there's no
time evolution at all in that theory so
you have to get time being emergent and
you can try to do that it's tricky there
are details that's for a whole other
podcast maybe
david boardman says
is there a way to describe what a low
entropy universe at the time of the big
bang looks like compared to a higher
entropy situation
um if by the time if what you mean by
the universe at the time of the big bang
is a very hot dense rapidly expanding
state the thing that makes it low
entropy is that is it is extraordinarily
smooth right it's homogeneous the same
amount of stuff at every different point
in the universe to a very good
approximation that is not what you would
expect in a high entropy state because
gravity is really really important right
if you have a bunch of particles in
space and you just let them evolve under
gravity they will come together they
will squeeze together and then become
more inhomogeneous they will not even
out because gravity sort of works in
that direction so a high entropy
version of the early universe would have
been wildly fluctuating from place to
place not at all small that's smooth not
all smooth sorry that smoothness is the
crucial ingredient
samuel benjamin says i've noticed from
your books and podcasts that you like to
use the term lucy goosey
see now you've now you told me that i'd
like to use that now i'm never going to
use it again now i'm going to be
self-conscious but okay probably you're
right
samuel continues please can i get a
shout out from my cats lucy and goose
their sisters who we've had since eight
weeks old lucy is a more conventional
cat in her behavior whilst goose is i
think more like ariel she likes to lie
in her bath after it's drained much like
ariel's morning shower routine so shout
out to lucy and goose how you doing
ellen g
what are your thoughts samuel continues
on giving animals the same rights as
humans do you think this would be
sensible and or practical
so at face value if i just take your
question as you've asked it uh no i
think that'd be crazy giving animals the
same rights as humans you know ants are
animals i don't want to give ants the
same rights as humans i don't want them
to vote i don't want them to be able to
drive uh there's a million ways in which
i i don't want to give animals and
humans the same rights now probably
you're thinking about animals that are a
little bit closer to human beings
behaviorally or evolutionarily like cats
and dogs or chimps or or pigs or
something like that um and and i am a
big believer that it's fuzzy right that
there's no hard bright line there either
between
animals that deserve rights and animals
that don't and there could be different
rights that are deserved by different
groups of animals
uh as i've sometimes mentioned before to
me like the single most crucial thing
that makes human beings special
is the ability to
as a species not every you know people
can have brain damage and things like
that but as a species we have the
ability to conceptualize the future in a
more intricate way than other species do
we have the ability to bargain on the
basis of future rewards to suggest
hypothetical situations to talk about
them symbolically make agreements with
each other contracts and all that stuff
and we and that ability brings with it
the ability to sort of um
be sad or be angry or be disturbed in
some way if our future is threatened
in ways that i don't think other animals
have maybe they have some and maybe i'm
wrong maybe future research shows that
i'm wrong in which case we update and we
change our minds but that's the most
important thing to me
and i think that's an important
distinction all these distinctions are
important again i i think that a
statement like i know you weren't trying
to say this but if someone were to say
give animals the same rights as humans
just way too simplistic i think it the
real reality is can be much more
complicated than that and we need to
understand and appreciate those
complications and deal with them roll up
our sleeves and try to figure out what
to do with them
robert henderson says my impression is
that it's not necessary to get into
quantum field theory when thinking about
quantum theory's foundational questions
that non-relativistic quantum mechanics
is sufficient is that so and if it is
can you say why
given the questions around locality and
the nature of space and time seem to be
relevant to interpretational questions
well you know again yes and no
is it necessary to get into quantum
field theory the quantum field theory is
a version of quantum mechanics okay it's
not a separate thing it's not like the
successor to quantum mechanics it's a
successor to non-relativistic quantum
mechanics quantum relativistic quantum
field theory in particular there's also
non-relativistic field theories but
usually
we take a shortcut and and refer to
non-relativistic quantum mechanics
versus relativistic quantum field theory
um
and anyway uh you know if there are
foundational issues with quantum theory
in general those foundational questions
matter just as much for quantum field
theory and just as much for
non-relativistic quantum mechanics so if
you take the idea that non-relativistic
quantum mechanics has a lot less sort of
mathematical baggage that it carries
around with it then you can focus in on
the foundational questions better by
thinking about that context than you
would in quantum field theory quantum
field theory has its own special
problems there's extra infinities as you
may have heard
so you have to renormalize and whatever
and when you get to the axiomatic level
it's harder to make sense of those
theories but those are separate theories
than what we normally think of as like
the measurement problem or the ontology
problems of quantum theory in general
now as you say
there are questions about locality and
nature of space and time
that are common to
the foundations of quantum mechanics and
to
relativity so
maybe
people are making a mistake by focusing
on non-relativistic quantum mechanics i
think that they are making a mistake in
it but in a subtle and sort of um
sideways way it's not that it's a
mistake
per se to think about non-relevant to
quantum mechanics but non-relativistic
quantum mechanics is formulated in a
fixed space-time background the
newtonian space-time background in
particular
and so i think it's just easy too easy
to sort of take for granted the
structure of space-time that that set of
assumptions gives you
rather than really thinking about what
life would be like without that uh set
of foundations to lean on right and so i
think that you know when people talk
about locality i mean let's put it this
way
there's a lot of people
in the world of the foundations of
quantum mechanics who say you know make
a big deal out of bell's inequality and
say like this is evidence for
non-locality and say this is the most
profound
result we ever have in the history of
physics etc etc
because it's violating locality and
einstein cared about locality a lot and
and my attitude is if you have quantum
gravity
you certainly don't have locality and
you shouldn't have locality you can't
you're if you think about a path
integral you're summing over many
different space-time geometries there's
no way to pinpoint a single point in
space uniquely in all those different
geometries at the same time
so the question is not from from my
point of view as someone who cares about
gravity and space-time
the question we should be asking is not
oh my goodness
physics is non-local what are we going
to do about it the question we should
ask is
why in the world does physics look local
as much as it does since gravity quantum
gravity anyway clearly should not be
local so that's a good question i don't
think we give enough attention to that
so in that sense i think you're
completely right uh people are missing
something by focusing on
non-relativistic qm
okay the last question for today's ama
for this month's ama bogdan veenatoru
says
russia has never given up in the last 30
years since the collapse of the ussr in
the hope that europe should remain
divided even against its will
it seems to me more than a war against
ukraine it is a war against the free
world perhaps the most difficult test
for democracy is it possible for people
to understand what a valuable gift
democracy is and to make us truly
appreciate and protect it as never
before so
look i'm not an expert on uh russian
history or
european history or asian history or
international relations or any of those
things so anything i say as usual and
for a question like this take with a
grain of salt um but but let me let me
distinguish between two things going on
here um
russia is a lot of democracy you know we
live in a world where
democracy has such good
resonance in people's minds that even
countries that are clearly not
democracies pretend to be democracies
ukraine really is a democracy there's a
little there's a little meme going
around that drives this home you know
who was the leader of russia uh and
ukraine and i think it was bello russia
also
you know 20 years ago 15 years ago 10
years ago five years ago now
uh for the ukraine it's different in
every single segment and for russia it's
the same in every single segment that's
the sign of not being a democracy
the opposition party never wins that's
what means you're not really in a
democracy okay
um
in some very real sense it is a threat
to democracy that a non-democracy like
russia can invade and conquer or attempt
to a democracy like the ukraine and that
is bad and we should fight against it
but
the long-term way to fight against it is
not to you know erect barriers to
autocratic regimes invading democracies
but to not have any autocratic regimes
to spread democracy worldwide so as much
as it is in some sense a threat to
democracy when russia invades the
ukraine and as much as a tragedy it is
in a lot of real ways
the things that worry me about democracy
are not being invaded by autocracies but
internal collapses
right there are plenty of countries that
have been democracies and stopped being
democracies and there's no guarantee
whatsoever that the united states or
canada or iceland or
uk or france or whatever could not be
one of those countries down the line
and part of it is
that uh there are powerful populist
forces that want to use rhetoric and
technology and misinformation and uh
resentment and alienation
among people who are not doing well in
different countries to
gain power in ways that have zero
respect for democracy
um you know there's
there's no question for any fair-minded
observer
that the republican party here in the
united states
uh is much less interested in the
trappings of democracy than it used to
be it used to be that as much as you
know you might have disagreed and i did
disagree with with republicans on
various political issues
we still stuck with the institutions of
democracy fairly straightforwardly you
know they they would try to
suppress votes by all means um but there
was still some
feeling that you know if the election
went one way you had to stick with it
right and
that's gone away and to a very large
degree you know some large number of
republicans still don't think that joe
biden won the election in the united
states
that's
the danger and the real danger is that
it's not just rhetoric that the people
who think this way
tried to overthrow the election they
sent in
fake
uh off
authorizations of uh electoral ballots
right to the national archives to try to
get on the record
that trump won the election in different
states even though he didn't and they
are now trying to take over state houses
and and judges and local election boards
so that if it happens again they can get
away with it that's the
worry that i would have about democracy
okay i mean the democracy's falling and
this is just the one i'm familiar with
the united states obviously other
countries have their own problems
but
democracies can very easily collapse
from within side
and furthermore just to be fair i don't
think this is a both side's issue it's
not like both sides do it equally badly
but
both sides have their problems
and to be in favor of democracy
means to give up
some of what you want right because if
you're in favor of democracy you're
saying that there's going to be a
majority vote and you're going to stick
with it even if you don't like it now
there has to be protection from minority
rights etc and that's important but
to enter into democracy is to enter in
the possibility that you will not get
what you want and there's just an
increasing number of people of all
political persuasions who just don't
think that way anymore they're not
willing to make the effort to gain power
by trying to persuade
people who don't agree with them to go
along with their policies they want to
use some other mechanism
democracy is hard
it's hard to make it work and you know
again you can be like cynical and say
well it's never worked blah blah blah
fine but it can work to different
degrees it can work more or less and it
is a lot less that we could have
democracy here in the united states than
we do right now and i'm very i'm very
worried that that might actually happen
um what i am cheered by
is among other things in the world i am
just cheered by those ukrainians you
know i feel very bad for them but those
people are fighting for their country
and for democracy and for their
sovereignty and they are doing so with
enormous
courage and uh in a way that just has
garnered respect of the whole world
there's another footnote here which is
of course that
we in the west tend to pay a lot more
attention when white people are being
attacked than when people of color are
being attacked so we do not give fair
media coverage to these kinds of
tragedies going on worldwide and there
are plenty of others other than in the
ukraine but that does not take away from
the tragedy that is going on in the
ukraine and the fact that their story
has been very inspirational and they
brought together people around the world
against uh the authoritative the
authoritarian regime that is trying to
take them over
so you know hopefully
people
start taking seriously yeah some people
obviously have for a long time but more
people start taking seriously the fact
that democracy is not guaranteed the
fact that it's hard work the fact that
it requires persuasion and cooperation
and compromise and coalition building
and you can't just stamp your foot and
get what you want that's what democracy
is all about
and to take seriously the fact that the
combination of democracy and capitalism
can leave some people in the lurch can
leave some people not prospering even
though the gdp goes up a lot of people
are not
uh participating in that wealth that's a
problem
and a good functioning long-term healthy
democracy will be good for everybody and
that's a that again doesn't happen
automatically you got to work at it i do
think it's possible i'm optimistic about
the prospects in the sense of
i do think it is possible to imagine
functioning
uh flourishing democratic institutions
in places like europe and the united
states and everywhere else in the world
that not only give people a vote but
give people economic opportunity and
give people the rights that they should
all have as human beings and with that
slightly optimistic note uh let's call
it an end for this month my voice is
giving out but thanks again for
supporting the mindscape podcast um hope
next month won't be late but you know
you never know it's in the future very
hard to make predictions about the
future take care bye
[Music]
you